foreign welcome to the Tuesday February
7th meeting of the science technology
and energy committee
as per our custom we will open today's
meeting by all rising and joining
representative Wendy Thomas as she leads
congratulations
for all
oh
thank you representative Wendy Thomas
so this morning
four Bills starting at nine o'clock with
House Bill 281 we'll break for lunch
we'll come back after lunch and at one
o'clock we'll have a
an executive session on several bills
and then at 2 30 we will resume
with two more public hearings
and hopefully we'll be done with the day
now as members of the House who have
been reading the calendar are well aware
the speaker has called a session for
next Tuesday
February 14th
Valentine's Day
so our committee cannot meet on Tuesday
next week
we have two options we can meet on
Thursday or we can meet on Friday I'm
currently
in negotiation with representative hunt
the chair of
the Commerce Committee who shares this
room with us to find out which of those
two days this room is available
I should know by the end of uh this
morning's session
whether we will be scheduling
hearings and executive sessions for next
Thursday or next Friday but I asked the
members to reserve both days just in
case
and that concludes uh
our announcements on committee business
so we can get down to committee business
so I would like to open a public hearing
on House Bill 281 relative to lease cost
integrated resource plans of utilities
and call on the Bill's Prime sponsor
representative Fred Platt
who was the chair of this the clerk of
this committee last session
and have him introduce this bill and say
welcome back Fred it's great to see you
thank you very much Mr chair it's great
to see a lot of familiar faces and I see
some new ones out there hope you enjoy
your stint in science technology and
energy I spent two terms second term is
Clerk and my life's been in the
utilities industry through Public
Service New Hampshire several other
places wound up with mass attorney
general and Rick office of ratepayer
advocacy similar to the job Don creese
is doing it's a consumer Advocate this
build is simple I've sat here the last
two terms and said why in the law is
still an integrated resource planning
requirement why does it still exist
because the utilities have all spun off
generation ever Source here in New
Hampshire being the last holdout but
that was several years ago so they have
no generation
um that's a free market essentially I
shouldn't say free but a market
regulated by ISO New England and uh
transmission is at a federal level
uh this planning transmission planning
at ASO New England and uh everything
goes to Federal Energy Regulatory
Commission for approval so what's left
is distribution and in my mind and uh
uh I'll get some disagreement from the
consumer Advocate which is fine uh the
in my mind distribution was quotidian
mundane boring uh it's it's just putting
a system together to meet the load and
it doesn't it isn't touched until enough
load is created or generation behind at
the end of the distribution so so things
have to be expanded
um and I ran this by the department of
energy they'll probably speak for
themselves but they were pleased with it
I didn't hear any pushback from uh
utilities but I expect that uh they're
concerned about consumer Advocates we'll
let the consumer Advocate Don creese
Express his concerns and I have offered
to the consumer Advocate that I am open
to compromise if something needs to get
back in there to have the dis
distribution to this file the
distribution plans fine uh but he's yet
to come up with some language and I'd be
happy to work with them and with that
I'll stop and ask if that if there's any
questions of me
thank you representative Platt for
introducing House Bill 281 and questions
representative Munds has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
coming in thank you I am one of those
new members
um what is a lease cost integrated
resource plan back when utilities had
generation
they could place the generation
strategically to avoid transmission
investment
and did that all the time and by
by careful planning minimize costs to
rate payers
because they get they have to pass a
Prudence test when they invest so they
want to be prudent with the money to try
to do at least cost uh and that's least
cost for rate payers and we used to do
Revenue requirements analyzes all the
time
and now that they don't own generation
they can't have that control of
transmission if a generator leaves and
there's a gap there they have to build
the transmission to cover that Gap with
voltage support and so on and so there's
no choice
and so there's some cost associated with
deregulation occurred by that we have
more transmission than I otherwise would
have had
the distribution has always been
let's say you do what you need to do and
nothing more so that really wasn't a
part of the picture recently this uh
there's micro grids and stuff like that
at a distribution level and in that case
the commission can and should have a
hearing on on the microgrid and whether
it'll pay for itself and so on so that
information should still be subject
within the purview of the puc regardless
of this legislation if I hope we answer
further questions for representative
plett
seeing none I want to thank you
representative for introducing this
legislation and call forward next from
the Department of ministry energy Mr Tom
Franz
please turn on the microphone
good morning chairman Bose and members
of sdne for those who don't know me I'm
Tom Frantz I'm the director of the
regulatory Support Division at the New
Hampshire Department of energy
I appear here today to state that the
New Hampshire Department of energy
supports HB 281 and we appreciate the
opportunity this morning to elaborate on
why we support HB 281
New Hampshire has a long history of
least cost planning going back to the
late 1980s I'm going to spend a little
bit of time on history and bring us up
to today I think that might be useful
for some of you
its history is tied to generation in
particular to the
nascent qualifying facilities industry
at the time qf says they are known
in the qf industry itself was
inextricably tied to the zebrook power
plant through the forecast of needs and
the development of avoided costs
and the understanding that that was
going to be a very expensive
power plant and perhaps there were
better options
so the New Hampshire Public Utilities
Commission stated in an important order
back in the uh
early days of lease cost planning it
said the objective of the integrated
lease cost resource plan is to satisfy
future Demand with optimal combination
of supply-side resources and demand side
programs thus the plan must provide a
comprehensive and detailed assessment of
all reasonably available demand side and
supply side utility investment options
to satisfy ratepayers
Energy Service needs at the lowest
overall costs consistent with the
reliable supply of electricity
the puc then went on to describe seven
areas that would require analysis and
reports
in order to meet those lease costs
integrated resource planning objectives
and of course those seven were the
forecasts of future demand assessment of
supply side options assessment of demand
side options
assessment of transmission integration
of demand and supply side options a
two-year implementation plan and of
course a calculation of devoided costs
and its forecast
the overarching theme then and for the
next decade was supply-side assessment
and treating demand side options on an
equivalent basis
that rationale change when generation
purchase power contracts were divested
as part of electric restructuring in the
late 1990s
for PSNH eversource that was completed
in 2002 and 18 and 17 in that period
with the sale of the fossil Hydro assets
and with that finals step of electric
restructuring one of the basic and
strongest reasons for least cost
integrated resource planning also ended
so where do we stand now
transmission planning is
as Mr Platt said
under the jurisdiction of the ferc and
ISO New England is authorized by ferc to
operate the New England power grid
administer the markets and conduct power
system planning
customers can shop for their supply from
registered competitive electric power
suppliers today and many do and for
those that don't
our electric utilities go out and
solicit six months competitive bids for
in short though the least cost
integrated
planning statute has evolved over time
it is costly resource intensive and no
longer necessary
besides Supply assessment which I've
just discussed
there are programs and proceedings for
other aspects that are in the statute
for distributed energy resources for
renewable energy
load management and of course Energy
Efficiency there are dockets at the puc
there are lots of volumes of materials
the utilities file Capital budgets
forecasts those are all reviewed
so the importance of a more reliable
resilient grid which cannot be
overstated
but it is currently being addressed
through numerous other proceedings
before the Public Utilities Commission
and perhaps most importantly through
distribution rate cases where the
commission is tasked with looking at and
certainly Department energy plays a
strong role in this looking at the
utilities decisions their costs their
Alternatives what they evaluated how
they evaluated them and then
making a decision on what should go into
customers rates
for those reasons I've just discussed
the department of energy supports
passage of HB 281
should you decide however to keep the
lease costs integrated resource planning
statutes but modify the current
structure and and language we will
gladly offer our assistance if needed
thank you Mr Franz members from the
commit questions for members of the
committee representative Harrington is
recognized for a question thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question uh just so I'm not we're not
confused here when you to differentiate
least cost planning as it had been
required to be done in the past and how
the utilities now go about setting
default service so people understand the
difference could you just briefly
explain that sure default Services set
every six months the utilities issue
rfps they go out and they solicit power
in wholesale markets they give estimates
of what the load will be
the wholesale Market a competitive
market although we wish it were more
competitive to be honest
um
response to those solicitations with
bids for 24 7 load following service
those competitive suppliers uh send in
their bids the utilities evaluate them
they choose what they believe is the
lowest uh cost option and they file them
with the Public Utilities Commission the
commission holds a hearing a quick
turnaround and approves those rates for
the following six months
quick follow-up
actually I just noticed you're a
co-sponsor on this bill so you're not
supposed to ask questions about as long
as I didn't speak on the bill I could
ask questions as a co-sponsor is that
the role I think that's the rule yeah
okay it's not the role as you remember
it's
all right I'll make it quick one way or
the other okay okay so the getting rid
of this law will not change the method
of uh uh coming up with default Service
rates then no it will not not change
default Service rates
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um current uh least cost plans under the
puc look at the environmental impacts if
we did away with these plans what would
replace Environmental Protections
well there are numerous Environmental
Protections already out there from the
on especially on uh generation from the
clean
Air Act of 1992 and its amendments and
those are uh
followed by all the generators that are
out there and over seen by the EPA as
well as the Department of Environmental
Services
follow up
um but nothing would be required you're
saying that there these protections are
out there but nothing would be required
I'm saying that what's required now
would still be required what we look at
in the least cost integrated resource
plans now we do look at environmental
effects of different choices we would
look at that as part of a utility rate
case for the decisions they make and why
they made perhaps a capital investment
why they put in a new substation instead
of perhaps using demand response or
distributed energy resource those those
things are when they actually move those
into rates we would look at that and
have looked at that as part of a rate
case
thank you
thank you representative Corman has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question Mr friends so
I want to follow up on on representative
Wendy Thomas's question so let's imagine
that that we did still require an
integrated at least so uh least cost
resource plan but that it was really
just focusing on distribution because
that's really all that's left
would there be any call to have a
section on environmental impacts are
there environmental impacts that would
be relevant there are always
environmental impacts that are I believe
are relevant any decision made has an
environmental economic social impact
you know but but I'll
representative munz has a question
thank you Mr chair so you know as you as
you heard me say I'm one of the new
members of this committee so I'm trying
to learn when I'm what I'm gathering is
that you know the integrated resource
plans are really trying to balance the
supply and demand issues and make sure
that there is a a mechanism or there was
a mechanism in place to that that that
service could be guaranteed to people
given the fact that
um you know things are are now kind of
dis disjointed I mean you've got as I
think you mentioned transmission is
handled by ferc and Supply is handled by
consumers generation is separate
who in the state is looking at that the
the overall picture to make sure that
overall there's an assurance that
um consumers will be able to get access
to energy when they need it uh
Department of energy has a group that
participates thoroughly
in the iso New England planning process
and we have members of group of other
committees that work on wholesale issues
so we also are the agency that's
issues the New Hampshire 10-year energy
strategy so I would say from that
perspective we're the main agency there
are other ones
but we're probably the main Agency for
the
overview of
generation in the region as well as in
New Hampshire and distribution now
obviously the Public Utilities
Commission
is tasked with determining what goes
into customers rates after a
adjudicative process
but we are as others behind me are uh
including the consumer Advocate very ad
for other questions representative
closure has a question uh thank you
cherith thank you Mr Francis for taking
my question
um
the department of Entry is new this
might be a POC question but from
the department of energy
what
this
statute was doing with the plans
policies and procedures it was a
workload took staff took caught it was
cost
from the Department of energy again
what could you say on the savings
to the state
when this no longer has to be done by
the PCC thank you well any proceeding
has an opportunity cost uh
the least cost integrated resource
planning
those filings come in they're about this
high and they end up being about
twice that high for those that are
recording this that's anywhere from a
four to six inch pile of paper that goes
up maybe up to 12 inches by the time the
proceedings over they require a lot of
data and Analysis there's a lot of uh
testimony filed on them there's a lot of
commitment of resources from a lot of
different people including from my group
and the dockets
last
much too long in my opinion we have
dockets that are uh I believe the puc is
still looking at a 2020 lease cost
integrated resource plan of PSNH
eversource 2021 from Unitil
um the Liberty one was
or the Intel one was just filed
Liberties is still open so
it requires a lot of resources a lot of
time a lot of energy and there are a lot
of costs and
opportunity costs are real costs
follow-up thank you chick um
so if this is repealed
and we have piles
of paperwork and submissions
if it's repealed those will disappear
but what about the reasons a lot of that
information we can get and do get uh
through other means either it was part
of a rate case when you totally comes to
change its rates part of the we require
and the puc requires that this rules the
number of filings that utilities make
concerning their Capital budgets
forecasts things of that nature uh I
don't there's a lot of valuable
information in the least cost integrated
resource plan I do not deny that however
we get a lot of that anyway and could
still get it
foreign
okay before we move on to the next
question or I just want to confirm to
the members that representative
Harrington is correct that as long as
you don't testify on a bill that you're
a co-sponsor of you can ask questions so
I apologize to representative Reynolds
yesterday I told you you couldn't ask
questions I'd forgotten we changed that
rule so I apologize to you for that and
I ask you to now ask your question of of
Mr Franz
thank you Mr chairman for that um do we
have a lot of witnesses for this bill a
lot of pink cars we have four more uh
Pink cards to go through all right I
just want to I'll make it a quick
question then uh I don't think I heard
you
um use the word or your predecessor
maybe but
um is it fair to describe integrated
resource planning as a relic of the old
vertically integrated highly regulated
centrally planned public utility system
that existed prior to what we now call
deregulation and things like the forward
capacity market and all that and that
this is long overdue
I mean would you just I I think it's
overdue I think it's a the statute has
evolved I think to try to uh
keep Pace with the changing environment
and the changing industry
um what happened back in the late 80s
90s leading up to restructuring I think
the statue made a lot of sense and I
think it lost a lot of its
rationale for existence with
restructuring
thank you representative Corman has a
question another question thank you Mr
chairman I just want to follow up on
representative plugger's question about
the actual uh cost to doe of of
complying
so you stated that we're looking at four
to six inches of paper maybe even up to
12 inches of paper would that still be
true if the report was covering only
distribution
well it mostly covers distribution even
now uh it's
it's really not just the paper I mean I
I don't wanna I'm just saying but the
filing's like but it's it's also the
resources it's the time the uh and
resources that go into the analysis
that's filed uh these the
many many many months and even years
that the dockets go on
and we address a lot of the issues
in other proceedings reliabilities
addressed in rape cases reliability and
resiliencies addressed through uh
vegetation management tree trimming
dockets like that
so there are a lot of aspects
that we do any way that are also
Incorporated in the least cost
integrated resource plans
and historically even if they may put in
and utilities have done this put it in
capital that really ended up in a rate
case that wasn't even in there these
cost integrated resource plan
and and to use the term the rate cases
where the rubber really meets the road
okay further questions for Mr Franz we
appreciate you being here I know you
have to get off to another meeting so uh
thank you and uh thank you we'll move on
thank you
next I'll call on our consumer Advocate
Mr Don creese and before Mr crease
begins I will point out to people who
are here for the public hearing on House
Bill 298 which was scheduled for 9 30.
I'll make you all aware that we are we
still have four pink cards to go for
the public hearing that we're currently
on so it's likely that public hearing
won't start until 10 o'clock or so
so if you have something else that you
need to do
just be aware of that
and with that I'll now turn the
microphone over to the consumer Advocate
good morning Mr crease good morning
chairman Vos thank you for the
opportunity to testify uh as has been
previously advertised my perspective on
this bill is somewhat different than the
previous couple of speakers I do thank
representative plett for introducing
this bill because I share his opinion
that our lease costs planning statute is
broken but I favor reform rather than
repeal and I would like to explain why
the premise of requiring utilities to
conduct lease cost planning remain sound
even in the era of restructuring
considered in isolation it is difficult
to argue with whatever the next capital
investment a utility intends to put into
rates is whether it's big or small but
without an eye on the big picture there
is a very real danger that the utility
were over will over build and service
will be more expensive than it needs to
be utilities I hope this isn't shocking
to anybody have every incentive to gold
plate their systems given the Paradigm
we use to set rates rate payers deserve
better than that someone keeping a
Vigilant eye on what total strategy the
utility is deploying in both the near
and the long term to assure safe and
reliable service at the lowest possible
cost
without an integrated resource planning
requirement the only real regulatory
oversight as Mr Frantz just testified
occurs after the fact after the utility
has made Capital Investments that will
automatically go into rates at the next
ensuing rate case if not sooner by then
the scrutiny just comes too late while
it's true that an investment can be
disallowed for purposes of rate recovery
after the fact in Practical terms that
never happens
for example beginning about a decade ago
a certain large utility I won't mention
its name but its initials are e
deliberately opted to avoid investing in
advanced metering infrastructure Ami by
opting instead for Less Advanced AMR
technology that had the effect of
pushing grid modernization farther into
the future than rate payers deserve and
by the way all of that exists within the
realm of a distribution service so the
idea that distribution service and what
utilities invest and don't invest in
their distribution infrastructure is
quotation that's a really great word and
I'm really glad that representative
Platt used it because usually I'm the
guy that gets accused of using the five
dollar words I just don't agree with
that there's nothing quotation about
what investments utilities are making in
their distribution system integrated
resource planning when done correctly
and when subject to correct oversight
prevents that sort of thing from
happening unfortunately at least since I
became consumer Advocate almost exactly
seven years ago the puc has not been
enforcing the least cost planning
statute the old puc by which I mean
prior to the appointment of the current
three Commissioners treated the least
cost planning statute as if it were an
opportunity to review each utilities
planning process as opposed to reviewing
the actual outcomes of the planning
process more recently
the puc has incorrectly in my view opted
to focus only on Capital Investments
instead of scrutinizing all available
options include though including those
that don't involve buying new toys and
the puc has treated integrated resource
planning as if its purpose is simply to
make Service as inexpensive as possible
instead of what the law actually says it
is and this goes to representative
Thomas's question make it as inexpensive
as possible while still advancing the
policy goals in the statute as stated in
RSA 378 37 two in particular that the
puc apparently doesn't like are
maximizing the use of cost-effective
Energy Efficiency
and protecting health and safety of
people as well as the physical
environment
so when I spoke with representative
plett about the bill and this is
consistent with the testimony he just
gave you he asked me this question what
information about each utility will be
Out Of Reach to you as consumer Advocate
if the IRP statute is repealed and the
answer more or less is nothing
but with all respect to my friend
representative plett he's asking the
wrong question
the IRP statute is not a transparency
regime like the right to know law it's a
statute that ensures or at least it
should ensure that the public has a
substantive role to play in planning the
future of our electric and natural gas
systems as well as our electric and
natural gas service and by the way
although it has been neglected by the
prior Witnesses the least cost planning
statute applies not just to our electric
distribution companies but to our local
Natural Gas Distribution companies
what I have in mind is an integrated
resource planning regime that offers
investor-owned utilities a grand bargain
of sorts open up democratize if you like
that word the planning process each
utility uses in exchange for
significantly less risk after the fact
of prudence related cost disallowances
so just to summarize I don't agree with
the idea that's all that's left from the
integrated resource planning perspective
is distribution Investments I think
there's plenty of room in New Hampshire
law for the utilities to plan
holistically and the puc to review their
plans holistically
I don't agree with the Department of
energy that lease cost planning is
costly resource intensive and no longer
necessary and I especially don't agree
that the least cost planning
plan requirement is just paperwork the
idea is that these plans are supposed to
be what actually guides these utilities
as they decide what to do what
investments to make what programs to
offer what options to pursue this is the
heart of utility regulation in this
state it pairs nicely with rate
regulation after the fact integrated
resource planning before before the fact
and doing in the statute would do
Grievous harm to the regulatory regime
that we use to assure that the interests
of customers and the interests of
shareholders are balanced against each
other therefore I have a request of the
committee give me a bit more time to
work with the utilities and other
stakeholders to come up with an
alternative to an outright repeal of the
IRP statute I do think we can get there
although I don't fancy being cast as the
lone defender of integrated resource
planning you folks are the elected
officials not me and if it's your
pleasure to repeal the statute you can
let me know that sooner rather than
later and I won't be trying to cut
against the grain of the Department of
energy and others who favor the bill I
think that's all I have to say by way of
uh prepared testimony I would if it's
the Chairman's pleasure be happy to
answer any questions
thank you Mr Chris appreciate your
perspective I do have a quick question
did I hear you correctly that you said
that you recommend opening up the
planning process to the public wouldn't
that add a tremendous amount of
additional time and cost to that
planning process
well somewhat like the way we handle
Energy Efficiency if you involve the
public or stakeholders early in the
process it avoids the kind of protracted
litigation that uh my friend Mr Frantz
referred to before so I would say not
necessarily but your your question is a
perceptive one in that it would require
the utilities to think carefully uh
about how best to involve the public in
that process and and by the way I I want
to concede that the utilities are
they're the ones with the franchises
they're the ones with the service
obligations they're the utility I'm not
I do not know how to run a utility they
do what I do know is what priorities and
options I think the utilities ought to
pursue in the best interest of
residential customers and I think it
would be useful if the utilities had the
benefit of that perspective and the
perspective of other stakeholders as
they plan and again these irps are not
supposed to be mere homework assignments
they are supposed to be the documents
that the utilities actually use to make
their resource allocation and strategic
decisions
okay thank you further questions for Mr
Chris representative Bernardi has a
question
thank you Mr chairman uh Mr Chris when
you started your testimony you talked
about utilities wanting to potentially
gold plate Construction Construction of
of facilities
um yet all your examples of where the
plan could be useful seemed to focus on
the distribution side including metering
and and whatnot so it seems to be a
disconnect as I listen to
um
representative plett's uh
bill which we're talking about
essentially eliminating a process that's
focused largely and was designed to
focus on construction of new power
production facilities it also has the
distribution component in it but
am I missing something did I miss the
this disconnect here I I I believe with
respect that you are missing a few
things I mean one is I'll give you an
example from the natural gas World a few
years ago one of the state's two Natural
Gas Utilities proposed a major plan they
wanted to build a pipeline down the
route 101 Corridor and a huge tank to
store liquefied natural gas that would
have doubled the size of that company's
rate base and whether or not you think
that project was a good idea
it should have been and in fact was
covered in that company's least cost
integrated resource plan so there are
major Investments for both electric and
Natural Gas Utilities to be made in in
in the distribution realm uh you uh
keyed on my reference to meters earlier
utilities have tens of millions of
dollars uh uh if not hundreds of
millions of dollars in their rate base
to reflect their meter Investments uh
and so the idea that there's nothing to
be scrutinized even if we're focusing
solely on distribution plant or
distribution Investments I I guess I
just disagree with that and I still
think that even in a uh era when the
utilities no longer own generation there
is still a place to consider the
generation implications of the capital
deployment decisions that utilities are
still making
I hope that was somewhat responsive
follow-up
so how does the utility plan for
distribution for a production facility
that they're not creating and they're
they're not in they're no they're not
the investor in they're not the producer
uh
the owner of well uh just to State a
couple of obvious examples uh if
utilities made major investments in
Energy Efficiency and by the way right
now they're not investing one cent in
Energy Efficiency that could have the
effect of reducing the cost to Consumers
that they pay to the generation
companies uh there's a bill that you're
hearing later this morning about micro
grids you know authorizing utilities I
think and other entities to commit to
microgrids that if deployed has the
effect of it has an effect on how much
electricity how much generation the
utilities have to purchase so even
though we have uh we we have
restructured the electric industry in a
very very significant way in the last 20
years but it's still one system and
customers still deserve a system that is
least cost from their perspective and if
the utility if the distribution utility
and the utility regulator aren't looking
at how can we do this in a least cost
way than nobody is I guarantee you ferc
isn't doing it I absolutely guarantee
you ISO New England isn't doing it and
so if the puc isn't doing it and our
local distribution companies aren't
doing it then nobody's doing it
thank you
since you mentioned it Mr crease I'm
going to point out to those assembled in
the room that house bill 558 which you
referred to in your answer to that last
question about micro grids and electric
grid resiliency that public hearing will
be open this morning but immediately
recessed at the request of the Bill's
sponsor
representative partial has a question
thank you chair and thank you for
joining us today
um I'm hoping he can help me parse this
out a little bit because to be frank I
am still struggling I think I tend to
favor renewal rather than repeal one of
the Clauses that would be repealed if I
may quote from the chapters chapter 378
38 number four
an assessment of distribution and
transmission requirements is necessary
including an assessment of the benefits
and costs of smart grid Technologies and
institution or extension of electric
utility programs designed to ensure a
more reliable and resilient grid to
prevent minimum outages
now I like all this I like it a lot and
I would hate to see that repealed and I
don't know who else would be
required I know it's a stack of paper
we're talking about but I'm hoping that
this last stack of paper they address
these kind of things because I don't
know what else they would address them
can you help me out with this well
indeed representative partial I I hope
and I think we all have a right to
expect that our utilities are taking all
of those questions and issues into
account regardless so the idea that the
IRP statute the integrated resource
planning statute forces the utilities to
do something they wouldn't otherwise do
I don't agree with that premise I mean
the utility should be doing those things
anyway with the IRP statute does is
requires them to account for the extent
to which they are doing that publicly
and subjects it to puc oversight that in
my respectful opinion is a good thing
thank you thank you
representative Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Don
I've found your your testimony and and
your responses here this morning to be
very persuasive uh but the question I
have for you is you you mentioned that
what you want the committee to do rather
than repeal is give you time to
work with the utilities to talk about
kind of a grand bargain where you would
have reformed to the IRP process in
exchange for greater certainty in the
rate making about investment recovery
but you earlier in your testimony said
that disallowance of Investments
almost never happens or never happens so
it's kind of certain so do you really
have any um any any leverage or uh would
you want that leverage to be part of
what we might put into
the instructions to the I don't know if
we're talking about a joint committee or
a
commission or just the process that you
want to engage the utilities in
but I guess my premise is that it would
be easier to prove that a utility has
failed to Faithfully execute its least
cost planning responsibilities than it
is to come in after the fact and say hey
utility you invested 40 million dollars
in AMR meters when you should have
invested 40 million 41 million dollars
in Ami meters and let's disallow that as
a a you know as imprudent I mean
it's just it's just a it's it's a matter
of what is practically possible given
the realities that we confront I I
personally my office has very good
relationships with the utilities and so
I have a lot of confidence in our
ability to collaborate effectively with
the utilities about their lease cost
planning we collaborate with the
utilities in a bunch of other Realms
already and and so I I part of my
advocacy is premised on the idea that
whatever we do by way of uh improving
the IRP statute would be complied with
by the utilities in good faith and I'm
confident that they would
okay we have three more people who want
to testify including a representative of
one of the utilities so we're just going
to take one more question here
representative Harrington
thank you and thank you for taking my
question you had mentioned a couple of
things you said that you didn't um you
weren't an expert in running a utility
the utilities were and then you went on
to talk about opening up the planning
process so it would seem as if you're
talking about having either your office
the department of energy or the general
public sort of sitting in with the
utility working with them to develop the
East cost least cost plan which to me is
doesn't go along with the idea that
they're the utility experts and most
people aren't so could you kind of
expose on that a little bit I'm a little
confused sure thank you for that
question representative Harrington I I
think that there are broad imperatives
that I and other stakeholders have
opinions about what I don't know about
is the engineering and technical details
of uh operating a utility and frankly
there are vast swaths of it that I don't
want to know I mean we're all very
concerned about cyber security I have no
idea and I shouldn't have any idea I
would suggest guest about how the
utilities ward off the very real threats
that no good and exposed to the security
of the grid but I do know what general
things I would like the utility to
accomplish and I would like the
opportunity to suggest those things to
the utility and then I want to hear them
come back at me with well gosh Don those
are great ideas but here's why some of
okay thank you Mr crease I think it's
now time to get the utilities
perspective on this question and I would
like to hear from Michael Licata of
foreign
and welcome good morning uh Mike Licata
representing eversource energy which if
memory serves starts with the letter e
um
I very much appreciate the opportunity
to testify before you today
um and candidly
really uh
appreciate the intent of the Bill's
sponsor as it pertains to the lcirp
statute and by and large agree with a
great deal of what was said by
uh the individuals who have testified in
support of this legislation I think in
many ways uh you know the lcirp statute
is I actually had written Relic
representative Reynolds uh Reynolds uh
so we are in agreement it's sort of a
Vestige of a bygone era of when
utilities were vertically integrated
which means we were
either owned or responsible for the
provision of generation transmission and
distribution today the utilities by and
large own
distribution and that is the the subject
of state regulatory proceedings at the
Public Utilities Commission and so
because you have this statute that
contemplated the consideration and
planning around other resources and
their integration into one another
it can cause a great deal of of
confusion
and inefficiency to try to Define how
the statute applies to the distribution
system today and just to give a few
examples I think
you know an assessment of Supply options
uh as you've heard me testify and many
other people testify including
um Mr Frantz earlier today director
France
you know our supply side options are
that we do six months
um load following rfps from the
marketplace and that is how we procure
default service there is the regional
greenhouse gas initiative which is
enshrined in statute and there is the
removable portfolio stat statute that
governs basically the the fuel mix the
the wrecks that we renewable energy
credits that we have to purchase
other options for Supply where if we
were an owner of generation and say had
a coal plant that was at the end of its
useful life and we're making a
determination of how and where to
replace that
would be the subject of of that
discussion
um similarly compliance with the Clean
Air Act of of 1990
um
if you own generation that you know
becomes much simpler uh evaluation if
you own poles and wires and substations
certainly there are environmental
impacts like every business but
how
compliance with the Clean Air Act can be
interpreted in many different ways by
many different parties which creates
confusion adds time and expense to to
the project and so
um
you know those are just a few examples
of how the statute uh you know
gets applied or
inefficiently gets applied today uh to
the utility planning process
um that said I I do uh
support uh what the consumer Advocate
testified to he did reach out to us
after this legislation was filed and
asked if we would be amenable to some
conversations around reform to see if
there was common ground to try to
address some of these issues we have
engaged him and other stakeholders in
that process I think it's been a healthy
exchange of ideas and respectfully asked
the committee to provide us and other
stakeholders a bit more time to see if
there's a pathway forward to make this
statute work a bit better and make sure
that there's uh understanding among the
parties and entities that
participate in these these proceedings
to avoid
um you know quite frankly folks being on
on separate pages with what is intended
by the statute uh and with that I'd be
happy to answer any questions the
committee may have
thank you appreciate the utility
perspective on this uh just proposed
legislation
I did I have a question for you I did
not hear the consumer Advocate suggest
in his testimony just what kind of
reforms might be proposed
other than kind of a broad uh
recommendation to open up the planning
process to the public
would the utilities feel comfortable
with involving
the public in a broad way
in planning how they run their business
yeah I I think um represent thank you
for the question and and I think also
representative Harrington's question uh
got at the heart of this that there's
there's a balance there
um that you know there are
policy decisions in any planning process
that are made that are informed by by
state policy and Regulation and I do
think and we've we have experience here
in the state of New Hampshire with our
Energy Efficiency planning we have
experience in in other jurisdictions
with grid modernization planning where
in the development of our in this case
lease cost integrated plan to uh
share our thinking and solicit input
from a group of stakeholders
as the consumer Advocates said could be
helpful to facilitate a more efficient
proceeding
um in the future so you know you're not
arguing over what is what is meant by
some of the statute statutory
requirements that there's you know
agreement before you sort of get to to
an adjudicative proceeding so I I think
that there's a balance there between
obviously the utility owning and
operating at system but also I do think
that there's an opportunity for for
stakeholder input
well as a follow-up I would ask let's
get a little bit more specific do you
think the public and stakeholders
stakeholders should be involved in the
process to plan interconnection for
example which is a pretty highly
technical aspect of utility operation
um
I think the engineering design of
interconnections to either
new
developments or or
uh distributed energy resources uh you
know that is a technical field that is
an operational field so uh I think the
evaluation of specific interconnections
um you know is the purview of the
utility to ensure a safe and reliable
system
so just to clarify you would not be in
favor of that part of the process being
opened up to stakeholders in the General
Public
uh correct the the review of specific
further questions representative
Reinhold has a question
well just thank you Mr chairman
following up on on the Chairman's
question and your response I hear you
saying and I agree that
public involvement or input into the
engineering
specifications and requirements of
interconnections probably out of the
realm of
of public input but
um
interconnection decisions more broadly
construed
whether to interconnect where to
interconnect what systems to
interconnect would you be open to
public input
um or and and I guess I'll expand that
you know interconnection policies and uh
would you be open to public input on
those
well there's uh the legislature has
directed the department of energy to
open up
um
uh you know an investigation into
interconnection policy I would say
standards
um so certainly there there is a process
ongoing right now to evaluate uh the the
process by which the utilities evaluate
interconnections and I think the intent
of that is to to achieve a level of
standardization
um so that developers sort of know the
the rules of the game regardless of what
um jurisdiction they're operating under
uh operating in so I I think that
there's a you know a lot of the
discussion around interconnection ends
up being on the cost and who pays for
the cost uh of those interconnections
um and what developers can bear so you
know those are policy decisions that uh
certainly you know the stakeholders the
commission uh the department of energy
and and the legislature has a a role in
I'll take one more question from
representative poche
uh thank you chair and thank you Mr
Lakota uh real quick
I got summary this is a relic
um others have said this utilities e or
something that
chose a different meter
that the PCU didn't
um
have an oversight on so my question is
instead of reform
this was a question I was going to ask a
previous testifier I'll ask you they
might come up again and
um
would repeal and replace be better
because this I'm afraid is going to go
back to
we're not following it again
just start fresh your view thank you
um
I think
reform uh I I don't know if you want to
call it repeal and replace but I think
it requires significant changes
um whether that's striking and replacing
all or or significant amendment to
um I think the point of
the current system is not working as
intended and significant changes uh need
to be made is is uh our opinion
okay I think we're going to move on here
thank you so much uh Mr locata I'm going
to call on Nick Krakoff from
conservation law Foundation I see you
have written testimony which is fine if
we could ask you to just summarize it or
good morning committee members um
my name is Nick Krakow from the
conservation law Foundation here in
Concord and I appreciate the opportunity
to testify um
as the chairman said you know I did
submit written testimony so I won't
summarize that but I will address a few
issues that have been raised today
um first and foremost with the what the
integrated resource planning statutes do
is they provide a big picture
opportunity for the Public Utilities
Commission to review utility planning
you know as Mr Franz said sure there are
many dockets where the commission
reviews many of the same decisions being
made by the by the utilities but this is
the only opportunity for the Public
Utilities Commission to take a big
picture look and provide that really
over oversight over what the utility is
doing you know is it simply not possible
to provide that same level of oversight
over utility planning and across 50 50
or so dockets and so
it's a much more efficient process to
use this uh the integrated resource
planning dock is to do this
um you know and as part of that I do
this holistic review of what a utility
is doing so they look at
um I urge you to read RSA 378-37
that that lays out what goes into um you
know what the state policy is and what
goes into an integrated resource plan
and if you look at that there's nothing
really in there that that you're not
going to like you know it requires plans
to be the least cost to highlight diver
energy diversity and protection the
environment and public health of the
state and so
you know without these statutes the
Public Utilities Commission is not going
to
consider the environmental impacts of
utility planning again Mr Fraun said
well you know there's a Clean Air Act
and there's environmental regulations by
Des and whatnot but
there's no other opportunity for the
Public Utilities Commission itself to
review the environmental impacts of
utility planning there simply is nothing
nothing else under New Hampshire law
that that provides the um the Public
Utilities Commission with that
opportunity so sure Des has its own
environmental regulations but when the
Public Utilities Commission is reviewing
these decisions
it's imperative that it also look at the
environmental impacts of these decisions
otherwise you know we're taking a very
siled view of what what the utilities
are planning
um
and so I urge you not to repeal this
bill
um you know I I agree with Mr crease and
others that there are rooms for
improvement and and how the planning
process takes place but repeal would be
a big mistake for New Hampshire it would
not provide the commission with the
opportunity to do this holistic review
of utility planning that takes into
account whether a plan is lease costs
whether it'll provide energy diversity
benefits and especially right now where
where a lot of folks um
you know energy bills are very high you
know a lot of that has due to a lack of
energy diversity in the state and so
energy diversity is very important if
we're not taking that holistic view Rate
rates are rates may go up
um and finally you know this is not a
relic of the past there's there's still
a lot of
you know a lot of um opportunity to to
employ these statutes for the public
interest and you know I work a lot on
the natural gas side which you know are
also subject to the integrated resource
planning and as Mr crease said one of
the Gas Utilities was was proposing a
450 million dollar pipeline
um you know so it's imperative that we
do this holistic review that the
commissioned this holistic review to not
only look at the cost but those
environmental impacts and that something
won't take place if these this these
statues are repealed so I urge the
committee to oppose
um the efforts to repeal the integrated
resource planning statutes and I'm happy
now further questions for Mr Krakow
representative partial
Sheriff hopes and welcome uh could you
tell me more about the uh
um energy diversity implications should
this bill be repealed should we go ahead
with the repeal yeah sure well
you know that right now we're over
dependent on certain resources for for
heating and for power generation
particularly natural gas you know you
can you can look at ISO New England's
reports and that that's backed up and so
you know if there are options to to
avoid Reliance on that you know increase
energy storage microgrids increase
Energy Efficiency to avoid increased
Reliance on those resources
um you know we should be exploring that
and without the integrated resource
plans there won't be an opportunity to
do that
representative munz has a question
no
okay so you know further questions we
thank you and ask Meredith Hatfield to
give us her perspective on this
thank you good morning
chairman Vos members of the committee
Meredith Hatfield for The Nature
Conservancy as someone who's had the
privilege of practicing before the puc
for a couple decades now I just wanted
to share my perspective and try not to
repeat many of the things that the
consumer Advocate said because we do
agree with many of his points we do
support reform not repeal and I would
respectfully commend to the committee
that you take a careful look at RSA
37837 which this bill would repeal
and that is the New Hampshire energy
policy guidance that is provided to the
puc which other speakers have referred
to
but it does say that it is the energy
policy of this state to meet the energy
needs of the citizens and businesses of
the state at the lowest reasonable cost
while providing for the reliability and
diversity of energy resources it goes on
to discuss as Mr crease said Energy
Efficiency demand side resources safety
health
and the future supplies of our resources
and as several other speakers have
mentioned there is no other opportunity
currently to have that bigger picture
conversation so I would be happy to
participate in discussions regarding how
to improve the statute I certainly think
it can be improved one idea I wanted to
mention is that some states do a
Statewide IRP process so that instead of
having to do a separate process with
each distribution utility
utilities come together and file their
own versions of an IRP but stakeholders
and the public are able to review them
together which I think might be more
efficient these proceedings are already
open to the public and I think that
that's a really important aspect of
requiring these plans is that anyone who
is interested those who represent
various consumers and developers and
others can participate in and I think
that's a really important part of the
process
and at a time when the state is seeking
serious questions uh answers to serious
questions around pricing of energy
access to new resources access to
Advanced metering
um how we get customers to be able to
take advantage of time varying rates
grid modernization which I believe is
still languishing in a docket that was
started in 2015. we have we do have a
lot of important questions before us and
these proceedings are the place to do
that I do think it definitely could be
improved I've been in many of these
proceedings and they can be frustrating
so certainly there's there's room for
improvement but I would respectfully
submit that they are not a relic that
planning and stepping back from a from
only being in dockets where utility is
asking for rate recovery is actually a
really important tool
in the IRP dockets are the place where
you can do that
thank you
thank you for your perspective on this
proposed legislation questions from the
committee
seeing none I thank you
representative McWilliams I didn't see
your hand thank you chair Vos um and
thank you Ms Hadfield for your testimony
today
um I would be interested to hear what
you think reform would look like if
there is something that you would
recommend
thank you for the question
um you know I I do think that while the
statute as Mr Franz hopefully reviewed
has been around for a long time
um and you know was originally intended
to look at the supply side if you look
at the filings today there's I think
typically a section where the utility
says you know we deal with Supply
differently now because we're fully
um deregulated so I I do think we could
go through the statute perhaps remove
the reference to the Clean Air Act
because that that doesn't seem to be
super relevant today and I think there
are other ways that we could
modernize the requirements of the
utilities the things that they should be
looking at the data they should be
providing so I certainly think and we
could possibly look to other states and
how they approach it
um so I don't think it would be an
extremely challenging effort bless you
um to to go through and make the statute
more more useful for everyone thank you
okay
one more question representative muns
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
coming in just just a quick follow-up to
that that question
what what would the the in your
estimation the time frame for being able
to do that I mean is that something that
could be done over this course of the
summer is that something that you know
is going to require you know maybe a
little longer
um thank you representative munz I think
what what I heard from those who
testified previously is is a very strong
willingness to come together right now
and bring something back to you so so I
would think that we we would be able to
do that in the short term
thank you okay thank you we're gonna
move on we have three more bills to hear
before the lunch break and so I'm going
to close the public hearing on House
Bill 281.
and open a public hearing on House Bill
298.
and I'm going to call the prime sponsor
of the proposed legislation
uh we'll get the blue sheet information
on this bill later
I'm going to call the prime sponsor of
the proposed legislation representative
Lucius partial to introduce the bill
and you owe me a pink card you're right
the floor is yours thank you chair and
thank you members of the committee
my impression is we will have more than
a few people wishing to testify and that
most of us on this committee are
familiar with what does at stake here
either through legislation brought last
year or discussions in caucus
with few exceptions I think you also
have a loose consensus on this matter
um so let's do a few quick comments 5G
is generally not wanted in our community
it depresses property values and raises
numerous environmental concerns
thanks to the FCC mandates 5c
contributes little to Municipal tax
rolls presently
we have enacted rsas designed to address
some of these challenges and I've
alluded them in my written testimony
which I did email to the committee
earlier
uh while there's a a risk and
while there is risk or not in the
Broadband application of 5G technology
and we uh and I doubt will come up with
all the answers today
however the difference in deploying such
things as Wi-Fi my home and flooding my
municipality with 5G is obvious one is
my personal decision to assume some risk
against perceived benefit the other
subjects all residents with a
municipality to a set of risks willing
or no
rather in view of the process in which
our committee decides to decide that
more legislation is better is needed I
will defer to those who wish to give
testimony for that reason I will end my
okay questions for representative
partial
seeing none I'll thank you for
introducing this legislation
and call forward the next person who
would like to testify on this bill with
Senator Denise ricciardi and Senator
richardi we welcome you to sdne nice to
see you again nice to see you too good
morning Mr chair and esteemed colleagues
thank you so much for your consideration
of House Bill 298 for the record I'm
Denise rashardi the state senator for
District 9 which spans from Bedford up
to Hinsdale
um I want to talk a little bit about why
I'm before you
a few years back Governor sununu had
appointed me to the 5G study commission
but what happened is it morphed into
more of the RF frequencies and it it
just morphed into something else so what
the commission quickly discovered is
that with the federal Telecommunications
Act of 1996 the federal legislature gave
the Federal Communications Commission
the ultimate power over states and their
municipalities when it comes to citing
issues it also
uh the FCC in partnership with the other
federal agencies that set acceptable
levels of RF radiation that can be
emitted from these sites
this law and the rules that followed
have confused municipalities as they
intend to have meaningful say inciting
decisions for many decades now
communities across New Hampshire are
fighting back to regain some control of
this process but in a way that does not
violate federal law
this bill is designed to give New
Hampshire municipalities more say
inciting decisions the approach set
forth in this bill is based upon the
knowledge of what seems to work and not
work as Community struggle with this
issue
I can tell you a week does not go by
that a constituent doesn't call me all
over our state asking for help with this
situation
um
the state the people in the state of New
Hampshire have a right to know that all
safety codes are followed when it comes
to cell towers and transmitting small
cell antennas especially in light of the
over 800 000 such Wireless facilities
the FCC is estimating will be needed for
new technologies so I want to stop a
minute and say this is not any intent or
intention to stop technology we're just
trying to give municipality some rights
on placement and we want safe
sustainable technology
this bill does three important things it
supports local authorities New
Hampshire's cities and towns in ensuring
that telecommunication networks meet
applicable codes
are appropriately located and most
importantly does not result in our
authorities being liable for damages
this is about safety responsibility
citing and liability
municipalities in New Hampshire should
be afforded as much Authority as
possible regarding Wireless facilities
and this bill is a very modest and
thoughtful step pending the energy
Department's development of a model
ordinance and the associated rulemaking
they are already charged to do that that
to do so for those of you who don't know
the fact that the energy department is
to develop a model ordinance has
recently come to my attention
12-k 8 deployment of personal wireless
service facilities and under model
ordinances and guidance States the
director of the Department of energy
shall develop a set model Municipal
ordinances relative to the deployment of
personal Wireless communication
facilities prior to development the
director shall hold one or more public
hearings and solicit comments from
interested parties the department of
energy shall provide a copy of the set
of model ordinances to any New Hampshire
municipality that requests it
I imagine most people think that um
over the course of the Tower and
wireless facility applicants must show
proof of meeting national state and
local safety codes including fire codes
but they do not
but in fact
k-112 B says it does not prevent local
authorities from enforcing building code
House Bill 298 requires that the
Wireless company demonstrate compliance
in the application from a licensed
engineer
that way if there is no upfront proof
the local Authority can give notice of
deficiency and stop the shot clock so
this bill supplements and facilitates
local Authority on these codes
as we learned last session for those of
you who were here in hearings on the
proposed
1640 foot setback for wireless
facilities
well some major why wildfires out west
were started by Wireless and electrical
equipment on poles for example in Malibu
California a poll loaded with antennas
of three Wireless carriers snapped
ignited the grass resulting in the
Malibu cannon fire which burned over six
square miles
the Nasi hardening requirements provide
the appropriate site conditions and
characteristics for wireless sites to
withstand things like severe storm
earthquakes tornadoes and other
disasters
second house bill 298 this bill ensures
that a wireless facility will not
significantly affect historical or
environmentally sensitive areas and this
is fully within localities authority to
consider appropriate location Wireless
installations should be responsibly
the sites need to withstand the
onslaught of natural man-made conditions
and consider the distinct requirements
for different Geographic locations
including the likelihood to be subject
by severe storms or earthquakes HB 298
concerns the liability issue so that the
low low calories are not stuck holding
the bag taxpayers should not be stuck
with this bill
this bill allows planning boards to hold
harmless
indemnify the local Authority New
Hampshire cities and towns for any costs
or losses related to such damages from
Wireless facilities
the planning board can also require if
it chooses that the Apple can carry
adequate liability coverage including
pollution Insurance all of this protects
our communities the reason pollution
Insurance could be needed is that the
radio frequency radiation emitted from
cell towers and small cell wireless
network antennas is generally defined as
pollution even by the Wireless company
insurance policies for cell phones
themselves so for example at T Mobile
insurance and Verizon total mobile
protection on ATT it's on page four for
them and on Verizon page 10 state that
coverage is excluded for pollutants
pollutants is defined as any solid
liquid gases or thermal irritant or
contaminant including smoke Vapor soot
fumes acid chemicals artificially
produced electric Fields magnetic field
electromagnetic field sound waste
microwaves and all artificially produced
ionizing or non-ionizing radiation and
waste many general liability insurance
plans have very clear electromagnetic
field exclusions for health or other
damages from long-term exposure to radio
frequency
I served on the New Hampshire Commission
on 5G health and environment and our
final report issued 15 recommendations
after more than a year of Investigation
into these issues
and I again want to reiterate that I am
contacted regularly by people who want
tougher laws related to this issue
they're concerned and they want safety
and they want enforcement they want a
calendar accountability and they want
the people of New Hampshire to come
first this is a very modest bill it's
important and critical step in this
direction there is a lot of work we can
do in the state in regards to this issue
so in short the bill provides the New
Hampshire municipalities with the tools
to work with the Telecommunications
industry in a collaborative manner to
ensure the safety of the communities in
our Granite State
thank you
thank you represent uh Senator rather
all the same almost forgot for your
testimony on this bill representative
Thomas has a question for you thank you
Mr chairman thank you senator for taking
my question
um so uh just to be clear does this bill
give municipalities
more information to look at if if
they're going to decide to allow a tower
to build in there in in their area or
does it uh give them more Authority uh
such like the puc might have for
sighting in the in the particular area
um I'm not well versed in that aspect of
it which which one of those two does
this give thank you for the question
what it does is it gives Clarity to the
municipalities that are confused because
often the industry
tells them that that they have no say
and they really do what it also does is
offer protections that they currently
follow up so uh in other words it it
gives them
more regulations if you will that they
can go back on if they decided either
for or against having them put the tower
there correct it will give them more
Authority but again it's always
important to remember without violating
federal law
thank you representative
representative Bernardi has a question
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
Senator uh so you mentioned in your
testimony that there's to be a model
ordinance prepared uh yet I I don't see
that in the uh in the bill that's in
front of us yes can you point it isn't
it isn't in the this bill but it was it
was in a bill uh it was in before it was
uh let's see the director of the
Department of energy it was 12k8 I
believe this was
um established after the 5G committee
um completed their report that took
place after so it's not in this bill
it's already in
um
12-k and 12-10
K10 and this will afford a wonderful
opportunity for the Department of energy
to proceed with the bill uh it was
referenced in in that original bill that
it uses the word shall in the
responsibilities of the Department of
energy
so it's not in the current bill because
it has already been passed
did I answer that okay for you okay
thank you great thank you uh rep Senator
I have a question for you as you read
this bill as you understand its language
line six of the bill
talks about adequate proof
by a licensed engineer
regarding an application to cite one of
these facilities
can you tell me does the does the phrase
adequate proof
introduce some ambiguity into this
process I mean what's adequate for you
may not be adequate for her
is that a possibility and should we
consider a amendment to tighten up that
language uh thank you for the question
what it we could do that but to explain
a little bit more right now
um when it comes to fire code they don't
have to use this engineer so this bill
is trying to say that we need an
engineer but I'm uh the sponsor of the
bill
um may want to consider tightening up
that language
if it is helpful to you
okay great thank you representative
Wendy Thomas has a question thank you Mr
chair
um on lines uh 22 and 23 where it says
the facilities and their operation will
not significantly affect historical or
environmentally sensitive areas that
sounds rather broad to me um can you
tell me how that would be measured and
what criteria would be used to determine
impact thank you
if you don't mind I'm going to defer to
a different expert on that is that okay
with you
that's fine thank you
representative Wendy Thomas keep that
question close by so that you can ask it
to someone else uh representative
Summers has a question
thank you Mr chairman uh first I must
state to the committee that I'm uh into
the record that I'm a founder and CEO of
a network engineering company secondly
that company is also a member of Bia
and my question is is uh for this
testimony I actually uh turned on my hot
spot and I have my Bluetooth running so
right now I'm facilitating 2.4 gigahertz
of self-service to everybody in the room
I'm also facilitating five gigahertz to
everybody in the room and representative
if I could just uh interrupt you
remember you want your questions to be
about the subject the language of the
Bill thank you so
whatever your question is Target it at
the language of the bill please I sure
will since right now I am a personal
wireless service facilitator
and I don't it wasn't my cell phone was
not operated by a licensed engineer and
there I don't have insurance as well
would that make me in violation of this
bill
I would have to say that this is about
the sighting of so if
the sponsor of the bill would like to
speak to that or to clear clear that
language up but this is not about your
usage of your phone or anything of that
nature this is about the site the
application and the citing of when the
tower would be implemented or projected
to be implemented
follow up follow up
um can you point out where it says Tower
pardon me
could you point in the bill I don't see
anywhere where it says siding or Tower
I'm gonna make a comment and then defer
to the sponsor on that I really really
want to make it clear uh given your
position and what you stated about the
Bia is that this is not to
stop change take away any technology
this is just about giving the
municipalities the opportunity to have
some Protections in place and have some
authority over their sighting
um but I will let the sponsor of the
bill follow up with you if that's okay
thank you thank you
representative munz has a question thank
you Mr chairman and thank you senator
for being here
um I I you know when I read when I read
the bill it looks like what this is
addressing is two things one is the
structural Integrity of the actual Tower
which is what Clause one gets to
section two gets at the environmental
impact and I just want to make sure that
I understand when when you when the when
when we're referring to environmental
impact that typically has to do with you
know impact on Wetlands uh that that
type of thing
um you know what is the debt what is
your definition of environmental impact
is it that is it that type of thing or
are we somehow getting into the area of
microwave emissions
I I'm gonna let the sponsor speak to his
bill on that I think that's more
appropriate
thank you okay further questions from uh
the committee
I'm sure there are other people who want
to testify that might be able to address
those questions
so Senator I know you are an extremely
busy lady so we'll let you get back to
your regular duties and we thank you for
testifying thank you very much and I
truly appreciate your consideration in
passing HB 298 thank you and have a
wonderful day thank you you too
next up let's hear from
Rick Fabrizio who represents the
business and industry Association
Mr Fabrizio welcome to sdne thank you
and good morning everyone uh Mr chairman
and committee members I'm Rick Fabrizio
director of communications and public
policy with the business and industry
Association New Hampshire Statewide
Chamber of Commerce and leading
nonpartisan business advocate
Bia opposes House Bill 298 because of
its potential to block new transmitters
in New Hampshire and this is at odds
with what state residents want and may
run a file the federal
Telecommunications Act
a Harris poll of New Hampshire
registered voters commissioned by ctia
found 78 percent of Voters support
Mobile Wireless upgrades in their
communities and 70 percent support
installation of small cell antennas
which are essential for 5G deployment
legislation passed last year and New
Hampshire ramps up the state's historic
investment in broadband and cell
coverage expansion to eliminate gaps to
benefit individuals
communities and the New Hampshire
economy HB 298 ignores that
additional local environmental and
historic preservation reviews are
redundant to State and FCC mandated
reviews
the Bill's standard for local
environmental review is boundless and
there'd be little basis to challenge a
site modification denial given its
unlimited scope
passing this bill will lead to
requirements that vary by town city town
city making compliance more expensive
with those additional costs borne by
consumers
even worse it could stop the expansion
of Wireless services in the state
local control is certainly to be an
issue considered with this bill but
consider that the New Hampshire office
of strategic initiatives States local
boards do have a great deal of influence
over proposed Wireless facilities but
they must be proactive and they must
remain within Federal Telecommunications
Act guidelines
section 704 of the ACT preserves local
zoning authority over the placement
construction and modification of
personal wireless service facilities
with limitations particularly stating
they shall not prohibit
uh or have the effect of prohibiting the
provision of Wireless uh personal
Wireless services
on the APCO point
the Bill's requirement to comply with
Association of Public Safety
Communications official standards
standards is inappropriate for cell
transmitters especially small cell sites
the APCO standard provides guidelines
for large Public Safety networks to be
built to withstore withstand storms and
natural disasters and doesn't generally
apply to commercial wireless networks
and even APCO establishes limits stating
the high cost associated with meeting
these requirements may not be feasible
at all sites in HB 298 ignores this
in the end HB 298 appears designed to
have the effect of prohibiting their
provision of personal Wireless Services
even as New Hampshire invests in a
telecommunication system needed for
safety and economic success HP 298 is
unnecessary its language is unreasonable
and counterproductive and it should be
defeated I'll be happy to take any
questions you may have
questions for Mr Fabrizio representative
Corman has a question thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Mr Fabrizio for
taking my question so you stated that 78
percent of Voters support Mobile
Wireless upgrades uh
do they also support structural
Integrity standards do they also support
um making sure that historical and
environmental impacts are taken into
account you would there would have to be
a con Paul conducted specific to that
issue the poll speaks to and I don't
think it's a surprise to anyone that
residences State largely would like to
see improved telecommune and improved
telecommunications system and whether
you do the poll or you simply understand
that when you leave a heavily populated
area
your cell service is soon in question
and in this day and age with uh remote
work with Telehealth Services the
broadening of how we communicate New
Hampshire needs to have a robust
representative Bernardi has a question
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you Mr
verizio
um so uh uh I asked this the senator
about the model ordinance and so I'm
going to ask you the the same thing uh
or a related
uh issue real relatively concerned so if
these standards are embedded into a
model ordinance so that throughout the
state you have a a uniform application
of them would that would that not
ameliorate some of your concerns
at the surface level yes however it
depends on which standards that are
Incorporated and how they're
Incorporated I go back to the APCO
standards that are designed for a very
specific type of you know a public
safety and e911 type of system they're
not applicable to small cell uh
transmitters it's to harden them against
storms and natural disasters it's it's
not the same scale so whether or not
that goes in
it's most important in the in the FCC
section of it it it does state that
there is local control in this but I'll
go to the notes on that that
um according to the FCC communities are
best served by having an ongoing
planning process led by a local Regional
telecommunications committee a municipal
master plan should include a
telecommunications section and the
community could identify locations where
facilities should or should not be using
the help of an engineer or industry
representative it's most important for
the communities to be proactive so
they're not
potentially having the effect of
stopping the deployment of personal
wireless service facilities because that
would run a file of the
Telecommunications Act
follow-up
so with respect to the appsco APCO
standard
if it's not in their own regulations if
it's not a applicable it's hard to
understand how it's going to be embedded
in a model ordinance
is that do you have the same it was news
to me today about the development of
this model ordinance
should that be the case one would have
to pause to consider whether this
legislation should Advance before that
uh work is done
because we at this point we don't really
know what the model ordinance would be
and we certainly haven't had an
opportunity to have public comment on it
representative Harrington has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um going to the um the lines there four
five six and seven when it talks about
these reviews being done by a licensed
engineer do you have any idea what the
time and cost would be involved to go
through all those codes and certify that
this particular application uh met all
the requirements no I I do not
um I do know that our our members vested
in this issue are concerned about
um with the duplicative reviews with
additional points of review that
compliance is going to be more expensive
and more burdensome it's going to cause
delays all of which is going to increase
cost for installation and all of those
costs are going to be passed on to
Consumers follow-up follow-up moving
down to line 19 I read this a number of
times maybe you're not the right person
to ask but since you're here I'm going
to ask you
inform itself of the environmental
impact of any proposed personal Wireless
services and goes on with this uh you
know except for radio frequency emission
inform who is itself in this case
I would ask the Bill's sponsor on that
okay all right thank you
representative munz has a question thank
you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
Fabrizio nice to see you again after so
many years who who knew we would see
each other again in this uh setting
there was always a chance
um it when I when I read your when I
read your testimony the third the
paragraph the third paragraph from the
bottom uh where you you you talk about
the environmental review is boundless I
mean you you seem to have a a similar
concern to what I had expressed earlier
about you know the what is the
definition of environmental impact right
can you can you talk and I'm
specifically interested in
as I said earlier I mean are we talking
about you know environmental impact in
the traditional sense of impact on
Wetlands or are we talking about
something that is that includes other
things like
microwaves
representative munz and I know each
other from my previous career as a
journalist uh on the Seacoast which I
had done for 24 years and really had
covered local developmental issues I
could say on that point of what
qualifies as environmental or what
qualifies this historic preservation is
virtually Limitless for those who want
to cite a particular issue yes Wetlands
that's an obvious one uh site
degradation is another one uh beyond
that when you you could get into animal
species it's it's literally in this case
boundless as to what someone could raise
as an environmental or even a historic
preservation concern and I would remind
again that both of those cell providers
anyone looking to put in a personal
wireless service facility is already
subject to those reviews uh through the
FCC and those reviews are specifically
the National Environmental Policy Act
and the National Historic preservation
Act all of them have to go through those
reviews
representative Thomas has another
question
that's uh Doug Thomas
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so uh given the statement
that the federal government
um
I guess regulation says that a
municipality Can't Stop
the placement of Wireless features per
se
where where in this bill does it
give the authority to the municipalities
that would prevent that instead of just
perhaps suggesting it should be placed
in a different direction or a different
place
well to uh be specific the language from
the FCC is to say shall not prohibit or
have the effect of prohibiting it means
overall it doesn't mean that communities
don't have the ability to say that's the
wrong site it's that you cannot develop
rules regulations ordinances that simply
ban the location or co-location of these
personal wireless service facilities as
far as the language and the Bill of
where it allows the primary concern is
the language May in fact allow
communities to reach that point where
they're prohibiting the installation
across the board and not site-specific
again because the vagaries related to
both the environmental and historic
preservation reviews
follow up
so um
therefore it seems like perhaps a
softening of the words or some Amendment
might alleviate some of your concerns
I think that if the amendment was
perhaps more driven by what is spelled
out by the FCC and the New Hampshire uh
office for strategic initiatives Again
by being proactive by having it be part
of the master plan of being able to say
where they can be located where they
cannot be located would remove some of
the subjectivity of this bill that is
the primary concern of the members who
for clarification I would point out that
the office of strategic initiatives no
longer exists and its duties have been
split up between the department of
energy and the business and
economic
Affairs Department
might not have gotten the title
department exactly that the previous
positions of the office are informing
the department of Energy's model
ordinance approach
okay I'd like to move on we now have
five uh thank you everyone people who
would like to testify on this
legislation
before we do that I'm going to open a
public hearing on House Bill
558 FN relative to electric microgrids
and electric grid resiliency
and recess that public hearing until
next week at a dime at a time to be
so with that we'll now move on to the
next presenter on House Bill 298 and
that is Cecilia Doucette of Ashland New
M.A for safe technology
I think I got that right and Ms Doucette
I would remind you that we're not
interested in hearing a rehash of the
findings of the commission on 5G
we're not interested particularly in
hearing about the health effects we're
interested in hearing about how this
specific legislation will affect
the people of New Hampshire and the
businesses of New Hampshire so try to
keep your remarks confined to the
specifics of the bill please thank you
we'll do chairman Vos and I do have some
answers to some of those other questions
at the end if anybody would like to
entertain those so good morning my name
is Cecilia Doucette and I am the
director of Massachusetts for safe
technology and I work very closely with
New Hampshire for safe technology I am
also the Education Services director for
the international non-profit Wireless
education thank you for voting last
session 15 to 3 bipartisan to pursue 5G
and wireless technology safety in New
Hampshire before you today are the final
report
of the commission to study the
environmental and health effects of
evolving 5G Technologies I encourage all
of you to get familiar with at least the
first 17 pages of the summary and
recommendations they spent a year
investigating
today House Bill 298 addresses the
commission's recommendation number seven
to safeguard New Hampshire communities
with responsibly placed cell towers
antennas and 5G small cell equipment
while the industry has told many
municipalities that they do not have a
say in where cell towers go that simply
is not true but our towns don't know it
there are many Provisions towns can
legally codify under current federal law
to protect their communities and HB 298
incorporates many of them one important
point from last session is that the FCC
has been sued for ignoring 11 000 pages
of scientific evidence of harm and the
attorney
who gave the oral arguments in that case
wrote the bylaw or the bill that's
before you today so he knows exactly
what you can and cannot do under federal
law
there are resources readily available to
help New Hampshire succeed the
non-profit Americans for responsible
technology has helped communities
Nationwide to adopt protective zoning
including Langley Washington
Encinitas California and Ithaca New York
and others
they have also developed this checklist
they have a smart planning provision for
municipalities
a sample code that your department of
energy could start with
every town is welcome to use these now
while the New Hampshire Department of
energy fulfills its mandate under Title
1 chapter 12 dash k
to develop a set of model ordinances as
Senator richardi indicated and in your
paperwork there today I've actually
given you a copy of what the current
statue is so that you can look at it and
you can read where the department of
energy under sections eight and nine
are mandated to provide sample
okay I'll give you a moment to look at
that
and that does actually ask that the
okay
there are many other resources the
department of energy can tap into and as
we saw through the commission process
there are World leading Engineers
Telecom experts scientists and doctors
at the ready to help New Hampshire give
the power back to their local
municipalities
and for for those of you and I know some
of you this comes way out of left field
on this topic today we are partnering
with New Hampshire for safe technology
to provide two free public educational
webinars every month we have people all
over the U.S all over the granite state
and even from Europe and Canada joining
us to learn what are the facts on this
issue and what can we do to ensure if we
choose to we use our personal property
safely but also to make sure our
communities are protected and please get
back to the bill itself thank you yeah
so lastly the international nonprofit
Wireless education has built a simple
course to train municipalities and
workforces on wireless risks and safer
Technology Solutions in about a half an
hour online so we are at the ready to
help New Hampshire the education
component was one additional piece that
your commit he voted 15-3 last session
that they would like to see moving
forward so I would be happy to answer
any questions that you may have
wonderful thank you very much
representative Harrington has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question I'll just ask the
same question that I asked before in
line 19 of the bill it starts out inform
itself of the environmental impact
learning proposed personal wireless
service who is itself in this case the
municipality
so follow up
yes follow up so the town is supposed to
do some kind of research and come to a
conclusion
to itself that there is outside of radio
frequency emissions that's that's under
the fcc's controlled that the facilities
and operation will not significantly
affect historical or environmentally
sensitive areas and I guess I would
repeat the kind of the previous question
that seems so wide open that you know
someone could say a tel a cell tower
across from a cemetery is a historic
Cemetery so we we don't want to have to
look at it when we bury people or
whatever it doesn't do you think that
needs a little more tightening up or
those con those conversations should
perhaps happen within the community so
that the community determines the most
appropriate placement of any
telecommunications equipment and by the
way when you look at that commission
report they recognize that wireless is
no longer advanced technology
future-proof technology is fiber optics
to and through the premises not more
Wireless build out so it is imperative
that our communities be taught that they
have legal recourse when the industry
comes in and says we're putting in a
cell tower in section 704 of the Telecom
Max says you can't say anything about it
because there's so much more that
Congress intended to empower our
municipalities than what the industry
representative Summers has a question
thank you Mr chairman and just uh to go
back to clarify basically what I was
asking them can I ask you kind of the
same thing is that in this bill it
doesn't actually State the word tower or
5G so if for example Topsfield Fair in
Massachusetts you're probably Familiar
of they have wireless access points all
over their entire entire area and
they're broadcasting on polls all over
there broadcasting wireless access would
they fall under this statute if they
this was in place
I would defer that you look to the title
one law here and it has the definitions
yes I think that's correct the
legislation before us amends
section
12 RSA 12K section 10 but there are
other sections
of that legislation which you very
hopefully passed out to us that show
that
essentially this entire section is about
governing deployment of personal wild
Wireless services so thank you for that
clarification representative munz has a
question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for uh
for being here this uh this morning I
have been struggling with the wording in
lines 20 through 22 in the bill where it
talks about other than with regard to
environmental effects or radio frequency
emissions that are consistent with FCC
regards yeah
um and I'll ask you and and if you can't
answer that's fine
my reading of that is that what it is
saying what this Bill is saying is that
essentially that the local Authority
doesn't have any
um any the local entity does not have
any authority over anything regarding
radio frequency Transmissions is that
correct that would be easy to see how
you would think that however there are
many many Provisions that legally you
can do in your towns the FCC when they
allowed the industry to heavily
influence the writing of the Telecom Act
of 1996 they did put in section 704 that
clause about
um basically if you have any concerns
about the environment you're out of luck
because you can't sue us
but there are many other Provisions that
Congress did allow that can be used
today by your towns to protect and the
reason why you really want to do this
now is that 5G means putting close range
cell towers people in Keene testified
last time they are literally putting
them in their front yards
and if you don't get your fire codes
right if you don't get the other codes
right and have an engineer certify that
when the industry submits that
application that it was done right you
could wind up with a cell tower in your
front yard and if you have a fire and
that comes down with radio frequency
radiation you can't just call
and get a fire truck and start hosing
that thing down they have to communicate
with the electrical authorities get the
power cut or the person holding the hose
is going to get electrocuted and we had
an expert with Susan Foster testify last
session on that so that fire code
Edition and the other additions that are
in that bill are critically important
okay representative Wendy Thomas has a
question
thank you Mr chair as you testified if
the towns can do this now but they don't
know about it is this bill necessary or
is this an education issue
I would say this bill is necessary
because our towns simply don't know and
they've only been given disinformation
by the industry and a lot of people are
getting sick from the radio frequency
radiation so we need to do something
meaningful now the commission Bill law
HB 522 was passed in 2019 and here we
are in 2023 and we have not done one
thing to educate or protect the children
the adults and the environment
okay I'd like to thank you for being
available to testify to us
is there any an additional question
representative Harrington thank you
thank you for taking my question and and
don't get the wrong way but I'm just
trying to figure out the the thought
behind this bill we've been dealing with
this issue now for a few years and the
big issue has always been the radio
frequency of missions and we had people
talking about headaches and getting sick
and so forth and so on and because I
guess of the Federal Regulations this
bill's explicitly comes out and says
other than the effects of radio
frequency emissions so is it kind of
like saying we know that's the big issue
but since we can't deal with it we're
going to try to create blocks another
it would be so much better if we had
been able to pass the Bill last session
that would have put a 500 meter 1 640
foot setback we wouldn't be having this
bill today but because the committee
didn't have a comfort level yet with the
facts around radio frequency radiation
emissions it was suggested that perhaps
we start with where we are in New
Hampshire law
see what got put in there to strip local
control and reverse that and that's what
HB 298 does thank you
I'd remind members that we have five
more people who want to testify
representative muns you have another
question okay
well I'd like to thank you Miss Doucette
for being here and testifying on this
bill and I'd like to call next on Deb
Hodgman who lives in Stratham New
Hampshire and is representing herself
Miss Hodgman Hodgdon
good morning welcome and thank you for
caring nice to see you Tony my name is
Deb Hodgson and I'm a long time res
resident of stratum I personally am
aware of the importance of understanding
the potential dangers from our current
technology I was fortunate in 2018 when
my State Rep Patrick abrami and state
senator Dr Tom Sherman both listened to
me and co-sponsored New Hampshire 522 in
2019.
this bill was bipartisan establishing a
commission to study the potential
effects of Wireless technology and New
Hampshire was the very first in the
nation to do so in November 2020 the
commission submitted its report and the
majority report had 15 recommendations
one of those relates to this exact Bill
House Bill 293 in 2023 I mean 298 and
2023 after its investigation the
commission understood the difficult
situation towns and cities could find
themselves in while trying to navigate
following federal law this bill
is the state supporting its
municipalities in maintaining some
control in this area in which they are
ultimately responsible
since 2020 the Commission in its report
has been used worldwide as a guide to
others as we all grapple with how to
best ensure the safety of the community
while providing the technology we all
depend upon it's fitting and reasonable
that New Hampshire should support its
own commission and continue to do what
New Hampshire does best regardless of
political party and support local
control thank you
thank you any questions
Miss Hodgdon
seeing none I thank you for your
testimony and call next on
Christine Matthews of Stratford New
Hampshire representing herself
welcome Ms Matthews
remember we are looking for testimony on
the bill itself
and uh
not uh extraneous issues thank you
thank you chair and members of the
Committees
most of my testimony is on the health
effects that have happened to me so
I will um
just keep that for
um for you guys to read
I support HB 298 because I believe
telecommunications should not have the
say and placement of salt Towers or
antennas in our towns I believe our town
should be educated well on the dangers
of radiation coming from the towers so
the towns can have safe zoning codes
that are safeguarded legally
in 2012 I first became injured by RF
and then I have all my health effects
and how
I actually became injured one and a half
years ago I moved from Pennsylvania to
New Hampshire
um to a tan with no cell phone towers to
heal
um
zoning Zoning for four cell towers was
approved for my town now which currently
now has no cell phone towers
I chose this town so I could heal
um if all four cell towers are
constructed according to the map of
zoning four zonings have already been
approved by the town of Stratford if all
four cell phone towers are constructed
the my home would receive overlapping RF
radiation from two of those cell phone
towers
I would also have to
quit working and just to
talk about here um I've been I was out
of work for three years because I was
near death
and um
I had to stop working to heal
since being here in New Hampshire a lot
of my test results have been able to
improve because I have kept my distance
from cell phone towers
and so seven months ago I was able to
get back into working
something that I didn't think would
happen so quickly but due to my tail not
having any cell phone towers I took just
a little job as waitressing two days a
week and
um
one of those four cell phone towers that
has been approved for zoning would go up
right near the only restaurant that is
in the town and I would have to stop
working again and I was denied social
social security disability
um
I gave a testimony around this time last
year for HB 1644 and I talked about how
I was around a hundred thousand dollars
in medical debt because insurance would
not cover
um
any of my bills I believe education is
key if I knew about the dangers of cell
phone towers in 2012 then I would have
never taken the job I am a research
scientist of almost 20 years I'm a
histologist
certified in that where I test human
tissue for cancer and disease
um
so when I finally found doctors that
were able to help me which took many
years
um I
I was given some of the the worst news
about what has happened to my body but
being um in the field of science
um I understood a lot of it which
kind of maybe was not so good because I
knew exactly what was happening to my
body and I knew that I was at very high
risk
for developing
cancer as well as diseases well we
sympathize with your your struggles
but we need to get back to the subject
of the pill and while your personal
history would be enjoyable for some
people to to discuss with you maybe we
could do that offline okay okay I do ask
for support
um from the House of Representatives
especially of Stratford
to um please help me
um
with uh stopping the construction of
four cell phone towers in my town
thank you great thank you very much for
testifying
seeing no questions I'll move on to the
next person on our list who is
Jeremy crumdel
thank you Mr chair and Mr Vice chair uh
Mr Fabrizio uh shared most of my
testimony and I know you guys are uh
short on time so I'm just going to share
a few key points but that's okay with
all of you
um yes my name is Jeremy Crandall I'm
here to testify on behalf of ctia the
wireless industry trade Association and
opposition to House Bill 298. CTI and
its members are strongly committed to
improving connectivity in this state
considering that on average residents
have nearly seven wireless devices in
their home
um responding to this exploding growth
ultimately very much is dependent on
regulatory certainty our members plot
out their budgets 18 to 24 months in
advance I mean I do just want to share
one stat related to how this helps
deliver both reliability and economic
growth for the state in New Hampshire
the wireless industry contributes over
one billion dollars to the state's
annual GDP and employs over 12 000
residents and so unfortunately there are
multiple elements of House Bill 298 that
would create this regulatory confusion
and those are the two two or three key
points that I'm going to share that Echo
a little bit what Mr Fabrizio said I
want to talk first of all about first of
all about the aspie appco standards this
has taken specific sorry let me start
with the that standard is not a health
and safety code instead it provides
guidelines as he shared related to
Public Safety networks to be able to
withstand the most extreme types of
weather events earthquakes tornadoes
severe storms but I want to quote two
items from their report that I'd be
happy to share with the committee quote
it is intended to assist Public Safety
Communications Network Builders with the
guidelines necessary to build hardened
Public Safety grade networks and that is
vastly different than a commercial uh
wireless network and here's one other
piece of this because I know that there
was a question related to cost also from
the report quote the high cost
associated with meeting these
requirements may not be feasible at all
sites and again this is talking about
Public Safety grade Communications
networks rather than commercial wireless
networks
I do also want to touch on because
there's been an important conversation
about the environmental impacts as well
as historical and cultural sites if you
are deploying infrastructure in any
state in any locality our our members
must first comply with a bevy of Federal
Communications Commission FCC
environmental regulations there must be
pre-construction review by qualified
experts as it relates to compliance with
the National Environmental Protection
act NEPA as Mr Fabrizio shared the
National Historic preservation act The
Endangered Species Act as well there
even if the the site is over 200 feet
tall there are also fafaa considerations
as well and the last piece that I'll
share is this I you know there's been a
really important conversation about the
role important role of local governments
this is from an FCC 2020 order says
localities could adopt quote generally
applicable building structural
electrical and and safety codes and
other laws codifying objective standards
reasonably related to health and safety
and so I just want to share that because
that role is very important and nothing
you know from our standpoint of opposing
this bill it's not about taking the
tools away from what localities and the
state and the federal government already
do as it relates to regulating a
wireless infrastructure so I will pause
there I'm happy to take any questions
but we do oppose House Bill 298 for
these reasons
thank you I appreciate your testimony
and I apologize for mispronouncing your
name that's okay make out your
handwriting there
so sorry about that so I serve on a
planning board in my town
and your written testimony talks about
how
this bill requires local zoning
authorities to conduct environmental
reviews
with a a process that is vague and
boundless can you
elaborate on what you mean by that yes
I'd be happy to Sir so if you look at
the bill and I've got it in here I
there's been some dialogue about how you
define quote invite I'm looking at line
19 environmental impact how would that
be defined how does this interplay with
already exist the already existing roles
of various state agencies here in New
Hampshire how does that uh interplay
with what the federal government already
does would just Echo what is already
well along the lines of the question
that you've already heard that we do
believe the way that that that section
A2 is written it is very vague and
boundless in terms of how those
standards would be applied in at the at
the locality level
so you Echo the question that
representative munz asked earlier about
the vagueness of the environmental yes
sir Alexander would share that so my
follow-up question would be
that your written testimony also states
that
this bill would
violate existing federal law
specifically the eligible facilities
requests
under section 6409a of the spectrum Act
of 2012. I believe res Senator ricciardi
testified that that has been tested in
court and found not to be the case can
you elaborate on why you believe this
would be a violation of federal law so
Mr chair uh I did hear Senator rashardi
uh say that I will have to get back to
you speaking to that specific case I'm
not I'm not entirely sure which case she
was referring to but I'd be happy to
follow up a follow-up with the committee
but I will point back to in my testimony
that quote about
um hold on I want to make sure I get it
right about what localities can adopt
related to generally applicable building
standards and and
where I'm going with that is that the
APCO ANSI hardening requirements are
incongruent with that FCC order and so
we do ultimately uh have the perspective
that including that standard in this
would run afoul of federal law because
of that order
okay but I'd be happy to get back to you
on the on the court case sir great thank
you representative munz has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um I I I think I heard something and I
just want to make sure that I heard it
correctly that the FCC is part of the of
the process you have to go through with
the FCC that they have some pretty
significant environmental tests or rules
that you have to follow uh already
um is that that I hear that correctly
that is exactly right sir and I will
just say last night I I pulled those
those standards up again I'd be happy to
send them to you it lays out a quite
extensive set of specifically
environmental standards related to NEPA
the National Environmental Protection
act related to I know there's a question
about historical preservation as well
um there was a piece in there about that
our members have to consult qualified
experts in advance to ensure compliance
with those and then the FCC has its own
well what I'm describing or what is
built into those FCC specifically
environmental regulations but yes
there's a significant set of them
so is there anything in the regulations
now that
um requires
um that um
a carrier submit those findings to a
local Authority for their review
so and and and just because I only get
one follow-up
um and
um and if not is that something that you
know that maybe could be something that
we add to the bill that makes it a
little bit more amenable to you so I
will so I would have to speak with our
members about the second part of your
question what I want to do is speak to
the first part of your question in terms
of the actual exchange of paperwork you
know when when the FCC does that review
and how our members share that
information with the locality I cannot
speak to but I will happily look into
what I can share is that there are a
range of items that local governments
right now regardless of the passage of
this bill a range of items that local
governments um in terms of their ability
to weigh in as you ask Mr Vice chair on
the placement the the code of the code
of abeyance obeyance of various building
codes and structural codes that already
exist in state law all of those
Provisions already exist in terms of the
actual transference of the paperwork I
would have to get back to you on that
part but I do very much want to
emphasize that localities have that
power right now and there's nothing that
this bill nothing if this bill were not
to pass nothing would change about that
that Dynamic but I'd happily give back
to you about that actual exchange of
information sir representative
Harrington has a question thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question as you're probably aware we've
been debating this issue here now for a
bunch of years we've heard a lot of
different people come in and testify to
health problems and different issues
that they're concerned about with this
given that and given that I think the
bill probably is going to be fixed up a
little bit in some areas we've talked
about would you be willing to work with
other people to come up with something
that's maybe a compromised piece of
legislation or is this looks like you
can't even consider this
uh representative in its current it the
bill as as drafted we have significant
concerns with it um really just to
emphasize again that regulatory
certainty that we are of the belief that
the the mission of what this bill is you
know and I won't speak for the sponsor
that obviously is their message to
convey
um all of those protections already
exist
um in terms of structural integrity and
otherwise
thank you
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um you've talked about regulations for
environmental standards that already
exist our health impacts considered and
if they are are there standards on
health impacts thank you uh
representative Thomas do you mean as it
pertains to environmental standards or
separately where Health standards
separately okay
um so what I can speak to is and and I
would be more than happy to I mean you
could go to it right now but there's a
website that we have
wirelesshealthfacts.org that speaks to
both the scientific consensus related to
5G and and health impacts but also
speaks to the role that our regulator
the Federal Communications Commission
plays
um in terms of deployment of Wireless
facilities every piece of infrastructure
you know from a from a cell tower to a
cell phone ultimately has to be approved
by our federal regulator the Federal
Communications Commission in a Range if
from the standpoint of a range of
representative cloje has a question uh
thank you chair thank you for taking my
question
um
going back to representative
Harrington's about
I have issues also the AP the Apple
if that wasn't in there if the
environment pack wasn't in there as a
um if someone gave me
an application
from another agency Federal I would like
to have to ask an engineering report on
it because I don't think they would be
referenced I have never seen that and
um I would like to ask you
that type of rewrite or working with
others if you could get back
to we represent and ask them those catch
things but the rest of the addition to
this amendment
um without those two I would would like
a feedback on that yeah excuse me sorry
I could ask the chair if he could ask
you for feedback on that for the
commission
uh I'm sorry I was looking up
wirelesshealthimpacts.org and I didn't
hear what your question is
representative closure do you need
something for me no thank you I was
asking for something personal or should
come to the committee
oh okay thank you
um
if I type in wireless help impacts all
oneword.org
wirelesshealthfacts.org yes facts is it
dot org or.com dot org dot org okay
thank you
any further questions
seeing none I'll call I'll thank you for
your testimony thank you call the next
individual
who is Deborah Chandler of South Hadley
Massachusetts and I'd remind Miss
Chandler that we're not here to hear
about the health impacts of Wireless
technology we're only interested in
hearing about
the specifics of this legislation
welcome thank you
thank you chairman I'm going to do my
best to
not upset the committee and to not
provide extraneous information but I had
pre-written this and yes it pertains to
in part to my health so feel free to cut
off my mic at any point
um good morning esteemed committee
members my name is Deborah Chandler and
I currently live in South Hadley Mass
and God willing I will be living up here
in the great state of New Hampshire in
the coming months
I am what is called a canary in the coal
mine I am part of the early warning
system with regards to the health
injuries caused by Wireless
I joined the 20 of the population that
has developed significant EMF
sensitivity and this number is growing
I can no longer safely participate in a
society that is saturated with wireless
tech without getting sick and needing
recovery time
I'm moving into the solutions part
um I can no longer work in my profession
and I'm low income as a result I'm
eligible for low-income 55 plus housing
but I cannot live in those places as
they are all saturated with Wi-Fi
to my knowledge there are no low-income
EMF safe housing communities anywhere in
New England
there are a few and far away States and
in other countries
so I've come up with a solution I'm
creating an EMF safe tiny house
community in a rural in rural New
Hampshire where there are no cell towers
within a few mile radius and as I embark
on this project I have at least 40
people showing strong interest
and shall I add need
we are all looking forward to finally
having a safe place to call home and as
a side note I'm working closely with the
New Hampshire Tiny House Legislative
folks
but as we move forward on this project
our looming concern is still this how
can we be sure that our home sweet home
stays EMF safe
every day cell towers are going up in
locations where folks nearby were not
consulted not warned and great harm has
been done
so dear committee members in my heart of
hearts I hope and pray that you will
please make sure that H.R 298 is passed
into law
and I am aware that this bill is not
specifically about health and disability
per se but it is about giving power back
to the people to the state and the local
governments
I have been very heartened that these
last few years
I'm sorry I've been very heartened these
last few years as New Hampshire has been
the first state in the nation to create
a special commission to study Wireless
harms and now let's put all that
research and knowledge into action as we
Empower and protect the people of the
great state of New Hampshire thank you
for focusing on solutions to this
important challenge
thank you for expressing your support
for this legislation we appreciate it
now I'd like to call on the final person
who wants to testify here today and
that's a person named Jalen I'm not sure
if that's a first name or a last name
could you state your full name for the
record hi it's Galen Beach
Campton New Hampshire thank you thank
you very much for having this committee
and representative partial and and
visuality for
um advancing this bill I would like to
express my support for this bill
um not necessarily as it stands but
simply for the reason that um I don't
see any other Avenue at the moment for
um trying to address what I find to be
or what is a kind of a difficult
situation
um
just to I'm a licensed certified
reflexologist a healthcare practitioner
apart from that
um I just wanted to let you know that
uh several weeks ago I was in Concord on
Main Street and I went shopping and it's
it was fine but I started to feel very
unwell I noticed that people in the
store were very you know kind of
agitated and things I took my
acoustimeter which is a a radio
frequency measuring device it's
calibrated it's you know it works I um
turned it on in my car outside and it
registered uh extreme levels of you know
that's the indication is get out of
there as quickly as possible it's
flashing red the static is shrieking
this is like North Main Street and
um it's right down the street from the
fire station and as I driven in I
noticed that there was this new short
fat
cell tower I had never noticed it before
it's full of 5G you know additions and
things
um it's right over the fire station I
went in and I talked to these guys and I
said uh is this new because
um I'm having a heart attack right now
and uh you guys are working in this
extreme
frequencies 5G the problem or the issue
I think with 5G is not
5G which is a marketing term but
excessive radio frequencies and
excessive microwave frequencies
emanating from our devices and our cell
phones and the arguments so far have
been something like well
mwmur radio station puts out you know
hundred thousand act at that every day
all day so what's the problem with just
adding more you know 5G is going to incr
has already increased four and five G's
has already increased the extreme levels
of of radio frequencies and microwaves
in our environment in this room when I
come in here I feel really crappy after
a few minutes but I come because I think
it's urgent anyways um when you talk
about environmental harm we're talking
about potentially this is
um
anecdotal to a degree but ever since
like 2018 there was a substantial
increase I believe in the output from
existing cell towers
um operated probably by Verizon at that
same particular time and especially at
the beginning in 2019 of the pandemic
there was a very solid increase in the
uh cyanobacteria blooms and algal blooms
in most of the fresh water bodies in
including some of the lakes in The Lakes
region of New Hampshire and that trend
has continued to increase so there's
some environmental problems potentially
with that
this beach I'll start to interrupt sorry
we appreciate your testimony but can you
apply it to this particular bill please
yes the ctia ETC talks about improving
connectivity I'm wondering how much is
um necessary and what is actually
required for connectivity I mean if I'm
in Concord right now and I'm trying to
you know get on on Wi-Fi or make a phone
call that would be easy to do
um but uh I don't want to be microwaved
and made ill because I want to go
shopping or come to Concord I'm just
concerned that there's absolutely no
regulation and no concern or
consideration about regulating what are
harmful biological uh problems so the
bill itself
um at least localities they may have the
power to do stuff but they don't know
know anything about 4 and 5G and the
effects of it they have not been
educated they've not been fully
explained
so
this bill at least May provide some
opportunity for this uh issue this
question this to find Solutions and to
be Advanced and to be considered
um okay well we thank you for expressing
your support to create a non-wifi Zone
it's there's lots of concern about
people having Wi-Fi connectivity what if
you cannot be within those frequencies
there needs to be some kind of effort
made to provide areas that do not have
Wi-Fi and if this bill or any other one
has the potential for enabling or to to
address that in any further way than I
support the bill sorry thank you for
your patience
thank you for expressing your support
for this legislation
and that is the final pink card that I
have on this legislation is there
anybody else who has not spoken who
would like to speak very briefly
seeing none
we will close the public hearing on
and I will open a public hearing on
House Bill 605 relative to solar
generation under the renewable portfolio
standard
however we are going to take a break for
lunch before we get into that bill
and we will resume our public hearing on
House Bill 605
after the lunch break and after an
executive session that occurs at one
o'clock so we anticipate uh hearing this
bill probably sometime around two
o'clock
so this committee is in on official
lunch break from now until one o'clock
thank you all for being here this
morning
everyone
it's now time to resume
stne activity for the day and our
schedule calls for exec sessions at one
o'clock this afternoon
but before we begin representative Doug
Thomas has an announcement he would like
to make to the full Committee just
something from uh this morning the the
clerk
for those of you that might possibly be
getting the calendar in the mail a hard
copy
um there there have been problems with
UPS in delivering on time so if anybody
here is has requested to get the
calendar in your in your mail
he wants to know that the clerk wants to
know what day you get it they want that
feedback
so they can provide that to the UPS
Thursday
give that information to the clerk you
don't have to give it to us here on the
committee
all right are we ready
I'm going to open an exact session on
House Bill 161 relative relative to
customer generators of electricity as
and I'm going to recess that exact
session why because at the public
hearing last week
Jim Monahan suggested that he wanted to
work with representative Harrington on
an amendment to get clarity as to
exactly how that the process of
group hosts under net metering
and customer generators in group net
metering would work
so we're going to give them a week's
time to come up with an amendment to
clarify that situation and we will
resume
this executive session
at a date to be noticed in the calendar
so since that
exact session is recessed I don't need
to close it because it hasn't reached
did you have a question representative
Thomas obviously ah okay
so
I will next open an executive session on
House Bill 81 which establishes a study
committee to examine all ancillary
charges for propane gas sales
and ditto with the previous Bill we're
going to recess this exact session
because next Wednesday
representative Thomas Doug Thomas that
is has scheduled a
subcommittee meeting
to decide exactly how to handle this
bill
will we go forward with creating a study
committee or might there be some
worthy of of consideration for that
executive session representative Thomas
thank you Mr chair and I just want to
add that
AmeriGas is going to bring two people
here next Wednesday at one o'clock and
talking to Mr Scully there will be at
least three other
good performing
um
a gas company Representatives here to
well to answer any questions and to
discuss any charges and and fees we're
working on a room number they've been
working on it all day we're trying to
find a place to meet but it will be at
one o'clock next Wednesday regardless
where we meet
representative regini have a question or
a comment thank you chairman you have a
question will this be streamed on
YouTube the subcommittee hearing thank
you
it is my understanding that subcommittee
meetings are not streamed
representative munz you have a comment
or a question thank you Mr chairman
could you just uh repeat again who the
they're in my notes somewhere but
um I don't remember off the top of my
head
representative Thomas has his notes open
and he'll read that he'll read the
members I believe it's a partial Sumner
summer uh Bernardi plouge and myself it
was what was announced
anyone is welcome to attend a
subcommittee meeting
I would be there myself except for the
fact that it's scheduled at the very
same time as a doctor appointment I have
all right so that takes care of HB 81
that could be a fairly exciting
subcommittee meeting so I'd urge you to
attend
so now I'm going to open a executive
session on the HB 381 relative to the
system benefits charge and I recognize
representative Harrington for a motion a
move to retain the bill
I recognize Doug Thomas second
it's been moved and seconded that we
retain house bill 381.
representative Harrington do you want to
um
comment on your just briefly there's
some changes that probably could be made
to improve the bill and I'd like to have
a chance to do that
okay any discussion on retaining House
Bill 381 representative Corman thank you
Mr chairman uh representative Harrington
I'm just curious can you characterize
briefly the nature of the changes you
have in mind
well there'd be a few but one of the
first ones that jumped out because I
have to do a little research on this was
it said that the prior approval could be
the passage of the legislature by the
general court or authorization by the
fiscal committee and I think it was Mr
crease brought that up that may not be
legal I don't I just don't know so
without researching further I couldn't
say but I obviously don't want to have
representative Wendy Thomas thank you Mr
chair um just an a clarification
question in the amendment would it
change any of the levels from uh you're
still talking about capping it at 2020
levels
uh that's for you representative I would
basically leave it the same unless
there's some reason to change it okay
you know I'm open to looking at it let
foreign
I'll ask the clerk to call the roll on
the question of retain for house bill
381.
Doug Thomas yes Janine nodder yes
Michael Harrington yes
Tom Dolan yes Abul Khan Lex barajny yes
JD Bernardi yes pomplish yes James
Summers yes Rebecca McWilliams yes
Linda Ryan
yes
Jennifer Morton yes lucious partial yes
Tony Kaplan yes
Henry Noel
yes
Wendy Thomas no
Thomas Corman no
Ned Reynolds no
six chairman Vose
yes
16 4.
I have out of 16 to 4
House Bill 381 is retained by the
committee
once that notice is made to the clerk we
cannot do anything with that bill until
so with that I'll close the exact
session on House Bill 381
and now I'm going to open an exact
and I will make the motion of ought to
pass on House Bill 385 and offer to the
20230360h and copies of that Amendment
will be forthcoming to you and I
recognize
representative Bernardi
I second the motion so it's been moved
and seconded that we judge HP 385 as
ought to pass with Amendment
but first we have to take up the
amendment itself and that's Amendment
zero two zero two three zero three six
zero h
which each of you should be receiving
uh momentarily
what this amendment does I'll explain it
as the paperwork is being passed around
what this amendment does is it adds
three things to the original bill as
outlined during his testimony by The
Honorable Clifton below
this past
I guess that was yesterday wasn't it
when we heard this bill
so the first change is on page one line
30.
the addition of the sentence for
non-residential rate payers the
department shall dock it and make plug
public any received complaint
that's the first change to the bill
the second change is on page two
starting at line one a new section is
added
which states that the procedure for
complaints is outlined in this section
shall apply to complaints filed with the
Department of energy on or after the
effective date of this act so any
complaint filed prior to the effective
date of this act would conform to
procedures that were in effect at that
time
and then the Third change to this bill
is the effective date on line four page
two this date this out act shall take
effect upon its passage rather than 60
days after its passage as it was
originally written and that was also a
recommendation of
Mr below who felt that
if
the ACT took effect took effect upon its
passage and might ameliorate the problem
described in section c of Section 3
rather even though he felt it was
necessary to add Section 3 as well
so that is the amendment and uh
I'd like to open the floor to a
discussion of the amendment before we
vote on it representative Reynolds has a
question
thank you Mr chairman yes a question I
the second
Amendment the second item in the
amendment I assume that the procedure
for complaints pursuant
as amended by this act
is that essentially the same uh
procedure for complaints that used to be
in the puc's purview is now the one that
that is correct so they
until this act
becomes effective
the procedure that's in place at the
Public Utilities Commission
to adjudicate these complaints will be
the procedure followed
thank you you're welcome
further discussion or questions
representative Wendy Thomas has a
comment thank you yes we heard from the
doe that that passage of this bill would
require the hiring of two separate
people does this amendment
um
affect that decision at all
this amendment does not address that
question and it may be relevant
but we had
contradictory testimony during the
public hearing uh some folks suggested
that staff would be needy needed
additional staff would be needed others
testified that it wouldn't so I suggest
we go forward with this bill and let the
Senate work that out if it becomes it
sounds good to me thank you
further comment representative munz
thank you Mr chairman I I'm still
struggling with the fact that we are
um inserting a second agency into the
process of reviewing complaints
um you know I I had mentioned during the
um during the hearing that you know the
way I read the bill and it appears that
the amendment hasn't changed that is
that you know a complaint uh and uh if
there's an issue with a decision by the
puc the complaint goes to the doe so now
the now the doe first has to understand
what the basis for the for the for the
um decision was so they've got to go
over to the puc and get all the files so
that they understand what they did
and then
um it gets it gets referred
back to the
um the puc if there's an issue and if
I'm somebody that's filing a
um a complaint
um I'm not going to have any Assurance
at all that I'm going to get a hearing
if the same agency that I'm complaining
about is the one that makes the ultimate
decision
and to me as I suggested in the hearing
to me the more fair approach is let the
puc do all of the due diligence on the
complaint make an initial decision and
then if they're still not resolution or
there's still a concern appeal that
decision to a a third party that you
know doesn't have a vested interest
thank you for that comment I would like
to comment on your comment
that's the problem that the addition of
section two a section three rather on
page two starting at line one seeks to
address
by
codifying that any complaint made before
the passage of this legislation
is adjudicated under an existing POC
process
then there will never be a transfer of
files from the puc to the DOE
it'll continue to be a puc
adjudication only new complaints filed
after the date of this pass of passage
of this legislation would be adjudicated
under the dot process described in the
substance of the bill
so you you sort of misunderstood the
point I guess of the amendment well I
maybe I did and if I if so I apologize
but I mean it it
if I understand correctly the body of
the language in section 2 talks about
what the process is going to be going
forward correct
correct and that process is that if
there's a complaint
then the doe will investigate it
and if the doe is able to resolve the
complaint
they will do so
and if they can't resolve the complaint
if there's a disagreement between the
doe and the complainant over the Doe's
resolution of the complaint then the
whole process can be taken to the puc
for an adjudicative process which is a
fact-based
uh examination of the question
okay I I don't I I don't think I
misunderstood then because that's that's
my concern that it's going from it's
going from the puc to the doe and then
back to the puc
well maybe if we use an analogy it could
help you uh understand let's say someone
commits a crime
the police investigate the crime and
then when they're satisfied they've
compiled the the
the facts of the case they take it to
the district's attorney the district
attorney
if he's satisfied that the facts of the
case warranted he takes it to the judge
and maybe a judge and a jury and they
decide whether the facts in the case as
presented as investigated
are
warrant a a conviction or an acquittal
the situation here would be similar
complaint gets filed it's kind of like a
crime and the doe is like the police
they investigate the crime and maybe
they can resolve it
because it's not really a crime it's a
it's a complaint maybe they can resolve
it but if they can't then
they take it to the judge which is the
puc but the judge is also the criminal
in your in your analogy no because the
judge is not the criminal
the the complaint is filed by a
municipality or a community aggregate
aggregator or a utility those are the
complainants
and it's not the puc who files the
complaint it's it's a it's a utility a
municipality a community aggregator
they're the ones who are alleging that
some kind of an offense has happened and
then the doe investigates and tries to
resolve it and if they can't then the
POC becomes the ultimate arbitrator but
the
but the the only reason the complainant
is filing a complaint is because they
believe that the puc
did something wrong a a a crime in your
analogy so no no okay they believe that
uh the poc's rules have been violated by
another party
has nothing to do with the puc itself
representative Harrington you had a
comment yeah this is not this is sort of
like the bigger change we did when we
switched from the just the puc and
created the department of energy and
it's not just here this same idea of
process where whoever is has a complaint
or an issue we take it to the Department
of energy they have the staff to perform
the investigation and if they can come
to resolution with the parties they come
to resolution there if one of the
parties doesn't feel as though they got
a fair shake or don't like what the
resolution was they can petition that to
go to the puc and as the chairman said
that would be a formal educative process
and then they would make a final ruling
and the puc would be based on that on
whether they thought the rules were
violated or not so it doesn't start with
the puc go to the doe then back to the
puc it goes directly to doe it's very
similar to the fact if if you're just a
utility customer and you have a problem
with since I'm looking at eversource and
um you would call the doe and you would
file a complaint and if you couldn't
work that issue out eventually it could
be brought up to the commission and they
would have an educative process and
hearings and make a decision on that and
as the same with any decision out of the
puc there's only one body that you can
appeal that to and that's the Supreme
Court
but Mr chair go ahead representative um
but all of this would have been would be
avoided if
the staff that was doing this when it
was part of the puc was returned to the
puc
if I may yes but that's not the case
they're not there anymore that was that
was the whole purpose for the
reorganization one of the purposes in
the creation of the Department of energy
and I just follow up on that by pointing
out that if you listen to the testimony
of The Honorable Cliff below he filed a
complaint on a similar issue with the
puc in 2017 and still hasn't gotten a
resolution
and part of the reason for that is
because
um when the puc and the doe were
separated the Staffing went from the POC
to the DOE
for doing compliance regulatory
investigations
representative Wendy Thomas has a
comment thank you Mr chair um I just
want to remind people that um during
testimony we heard that there are on
average two to three complaints a year
and there was some discussion about
whether or not this was a solution
further comments on this question
yes I could share
um
I'm knowing that the DU the doe is
already has a Workforce of 65 people and
hearing that it's going to be necessary
to hire additional Personnel to handle
this I know we're sensitive handling to
hiring additional Personnel because of
our recent Green Bank
um Bill we were concerned about having
hired another additional Personnel for
that my question would be could you
explain why that additional Personnel is
not already present in the doae if they
there are Personnel in the DOA doe in
the compliance division that do exactly
so the uh follow-up this if I can follow
up
um so the uh speculation that we would
need a higher additional Personnel it
could be very well unfounded it was yeah
this is what the doe testified
yes we heard testimony both ways uh
somebody we heard testimony that said
they may need new staff and we heard
testimony that said it's unlikely that
they would need new staff okay thank you
those of us who have been following
following the
uh development of the new house budget
will have heard that the department of
energy is already asking for some staff
increases in the in the uh in its new
budget so it's it's
at least possible that adequate Staffing
will be there for
the relatively small number of
complaints
that are likely to occur now the reason
this bill exists one of the reasons this
bill exists is because
Community aggregation doesn't actually
exist yet in practice it's just a a
theory at this point or a a piece of
legislation and so it's not really known
how many complaints may eventually arise
but it's not likely that
any significant number of complaints
will arise in the next year
nevertheless the commission felt it
would be a good idea to have a process
in place to deal with that
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the role on the question of the adoption
Doug Thomas
yes
Janine Nader yes
Michael Harrington yes Tom Dolan yes a
bull Khan yes Lex barajny yes JD
Bernardi yes Tom poche yes James Summers
yes Rebecca McWilliams yes
Linda Ryan yes
Jennifer Norton Morton Excuse me yes
lucious partial yes
Tony Kaplan yes Christopher muns yeah
yes
Henry Knoll yes
Wendy Thomas yes
Thomas Corman yes
Ned Reynolds yes chairman Bose yes
20-0
by a vote of 20-0 the amendment is
adopted I will now move
ought to pass as amended and recognized
Doug Thomas that is
second
sorry representative Wendy Thomas
so it's been moved and seconded that we
adopt
House Bill 3 6 385 rather as amended by
Amendment
2023-03608 is there any further
discussion
representative munz thank you Mr
chairman I'm not going to let the
perfect get in the way of the good and
uh we'll be supporting this this uh
amended bill
none I asked the clerk to call the role
on the question of ought to pass as
amended on HB 385
Doug Thomas yes Janine Nutter yes
Michael Harrington yes Tom Dolan yes
Abul Khan yes Lex barajny yes JD
Bernardi yes Tom plushie yes James
Summers yes Rebecca McWilliams yes
Linda Ryan yes
Jennifer Morton yes lucious partial yes
Tony Kaplan yes
Chris muns yes with enthusiasm
Henry Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes Thomas
Corman yes Ned Reynolds yes chairman
Bose yes 20-0 by a vote of 20-0 House
Bill 385 as amended by
amendment
0360h is adopted by the committee and
seeing no objection so ordered this bill
will be on the consent calendar
and with that we'll close the public of
the exact session on House Bill 385 and
we'll thank Representatives Ryan and
Morton and representative stolen and
Khan for substituting today I'm sorry I
didn't
introduce you at the beginning of the
exact session I forgot
but we thank you for being here and if
you should need to go elsewhere
feel free or if you'd like to stay and
hear the discussion on three more public
hearings three more bills that we're
having public hearings for you're
welcome to do that as well I'll leave
now before we broke for lunch I opened
the public hearing on House Bill 605.
and then we took a lunch break
so that means that we can resume this
public hearing
at any time
and so I would like to do so right now
by inviting the Bill's Prime sponsor
representative Reynolds to present this
and I would alert anyone in the audience
that if you want to speak on this bill
please submit a pink card at your
earliest convenience
and representative Reynolds that
includes you too
you don't have to do it right away but
after you finish introducing the bill
whenever you're ready
thank you Mr chairman
good afternoon
Mr chairman and members of the committee
my name is Ned Reynolds and I represent
the citizens of house district
Rockingham number 39 better understood
as
the residents of three-fifths of the
city of Portsmouth
prior to serving in the legislature I
worked professionally for over 25 years
in the energy field
starting in 1996 with the Lawrence
Berkeley National Laboratory working on
the energy star program
back in its infancy and uh
culminating last year in about three and
as a commercial
sales consultant for revision energy a
new hampshire-based Solar Company with
substantial well it's New Hampshire
headquarters in uh chairman voses
and the transit I made a transition
about
from the sort of government nonprofit
sector into the
business side of of clean energy
uh actually working for Unitil I worked
for
a year and a half 18 months for Unitil
in fact directly for Cindy Carroll who
you may remember presented to this
committee on behalf of Unitil a few
weeks ago so anyway that background my
uh my bill
House Bill 605 is is very
straightforward
it uh seeks to have new state of New
Hampshire Take the Long View on the
important task
of this legislature in ensuring a
low-cost and diverse portfolio
uh for default service the default
service rate payers of New Hampshire
by requiring
our investor-owned utilities to procure
in their default Service Supply
gradually increasing amounts of
um referring to the one side of the
handout
that I just handed out the one well both
of them of course
came from
the handout we got from ISO New England
a few weeks ago
it's no secret that among the states all
the states in New in New England
New Hampshire is by far the least
ambitious with our renewable portfolio
standard
and in times past it could reasonably be
claimed that New Hampshire did this so
as to protect its rate payers from
bearing the costs of forcing utilities
to buy renewable energy
which was often more expensive
well
the rate shock that all utility
customers in New Hampshire indeed in New
England are actually the entire world
are experiencing now
in the wake of Russia's invasion of
Ukraine and other
Global developments like inflation
and the rapid jump in global fossil fuel
prices means that those days are indeed
in the past
if I could get all the members of this
committee to really and truly grasp
one thing it would be this
all of us all New Hampshire residents
and businesses are price takers
of those fossil fuels
on the global market
it is global supply and demand and world
events like Wars hurricanes terrorist
attacks ships getting stuck sideways in
canals
whatever that determine
the price ups and downs of fossil fuels
we have no control
New Hampshire has no fossil fuels we are
not Texas
Wyoming West Virginia or even
Pennsylvania
which is another Northeast State that
does participate in Reggie
are dependence on natural gas and oil
for the vast majority of heating and
nearly 60 percent of electricity
generation at Peak demand times is an
enormous vulnerability
and economic weakness for our state
when it comes to utility rates
the utilities
go to the puc every six months
and they tell
the puc and the public
this is what happened to the price of
fossil fuels
so this is what our rates must be we
must pass through the cost of that to
ratepayers and the puc really has no
chance no other choice than to say
you know okay you're right that's the
cost of
fossil fuel on the global market
everybody knows it no amount of outrage
or Bluster or claims that we're going to
give them rate relief
in the short term can change that fact
this dependence and vulnerability to the
global fossil fuel Market are
antithetical to New Hampshire's prized
values of self-reliance Independence
taking care of our own the six billion
dollars over six billion dollars
that we spend on fossil fuels every year
think about that 500 million dollars
every month spent in New Hampshire on
fossil fuels that represents over two
percent of our state's GDP
we send out of state to power our
economy that represents lost opportunity
vulnerability and export of New
Hampshire's wealth and resources if we
care about price and we care about rates
and we all do
we all do
then we must use every tool we have to
achieve increased portfolio diversity
which enhances our strength and
resilience
in the face of global fossil fuel
markets diversity reduces risk
it reduces demand especially at peak
times when spot prices on the regional
market are highest and thus it lowers
rates it
exerts downward pressure on rates
it is policy Maker's responsibility our
responsibility our constituents expect
us to have foresight and the willingness
to understand the emerging energy
landscape the capabilities and
advantages offered by new technology and
make policies that look over the horizon
to where we need to be 5 10. 20 30 years
from now
and begin to turn the massive ship
that is our Energy System
renewable energy has the singular virtue
of having zero fuel costs
let me repeat that the fuel cost of
renewable energy
is zero and will always be zero
many on this committee have expressed
deep skepticism about renewable energy
the value of renewable energy because
it's not always available that is only
when the sun is shining or the wind is
blowing
and of course that statement is correct
though it's rapidly being rendered
incorrect by the emerging uh by the
emergence of energy storage Technologies
members of this committee shouldn't
concern themselves
with that that fact of intermittency in
Renewables because as we've heard in
testimony everyone
we our utilities and the regional grid
operator all understand that the fact of
intermittency of Renewables it's
accounted for by assigning them a low
capacity factor in the regional forward
capacity market so their value is
discounted
but we've also heard repeated testimony
that the way the regional power Market
operates power is always dispatched
economically
that is from the cheapest to the most
expensive
renewable energy which has zero fuel
costs is very cheap when it's available
when it's available it should be used
and when it's used it reduces demand for
electricity from power plants powered by
what is by far the largest source of
non-renewable fuel currently has very
high fuel costs which is natural gas and
this would leave that natural gas
available to be used another day another
cloudy day
or another cold night when solar is not
available
so
now I'd like to refer you to the other
side of the handout
which again came from ISO New England
the current and certainly historical
impact of distributed solar
behind the meter solar as well as Energy
Efficiency but we're focusing on
distributed solar here today
it was the regional grid operator the
non-profit
Regional grid operator the one that's
forecasting demand ensuring sufficient
Supply
they told us that distributed solar
has had and is projected to continue to
have significant
downward effect on
Regional demand and that Regional that
reduction in growth in Regional demand
will lower the cost of wholesale power
which will flow through the Retail
Energy costs that the utilities present
in rate cases
and that appears you know on our on our
a significant policy that New Hampshire
has had on its books for many years
is an important Market signal
and we should use it to good effect
it's an important Market signal that
says to the private Developers
or private businesses even residential
homeowners build more solar
do more of this
so we should do it so we should
strengthen the RPS and that's what my
build does
it
takes the anemic
numbers the
worst in the New England and probably
worst in the country uh
Market signal that the state sends for
for solar PV and it increases it
modestly
modestly over the next
25 years to 2050.
and we should send that signal to the
market for the benefit of our
selves and our ratepayers and our great
state of New Hampshire and with that
I'll be
thank you very much for introducing this
bill representative Summers has a
question for you thank you Mr chairman
thank you just uh quick questions
looking over this and I just have a base
question for you on
a great job of describing the supply of
Renewables and I know on our electric
bills we have two sections we have the
supply and we have the transmission well
I'm wondering is as the Val the
availability of it and the transmission
the supply goes up
um but what I don't see and I don't
understand even the cost benefit when
you figure in and we know because of
testimony the puc stated the utilities
rate make their profit off the capital
cause the cost capital on the
transmission lines the cost of the
transmission to be able to provide wind
and solar to everybody out here what the
cost difference and how much that would
yeah I'm not sure what you're asking me
there my question is would these would
these with the is the renewable energy
rates as increase as high as you show
here with an increase on the bill as you
show here will that be actually
um
counterproductive to the amount of cost
it would be to the payers when they have
to realize the utilize the transmission
cost as well
well I'll take a stab at that I think
the cost of what are what our investor
owned utilities whatever Source Liberty
um Unitil I'll do the co-op they they
now as we know run trans uh Distribution
Systems local Distribution Systems and
um
they
other private owners uh own and operate
the regional larger high voltage
transmission system and all of them
um
you know those costs are what are
submitted to the puc to go into rates
look
upgrade the distribution system
no matter where the supply is coming
from we have to have a distribution
system and it has to be maintained and
upgraded and made resilient so I don't I
do not feel that uh requiring more uh
solar
would add increased transmission or
distribution costs in fact there's
substantial evidence that adding
distributed solar throughout the system
reduces
the need for expensive transmission
upgrades because you're not having to
bring large amounts of bulk power from
far away rather you are having small
amounts of distributed generation put
onto the grid
throughout the grid
and where there are upgrades to
distribution to local Distribution
Systems required
for example a project I worked on at
revision energy before I left the town
of Exeter contemplating a
1.8 megawatt
um
solar array on their landfill
one of your most important steps is to
submit an interconnection application to
eversource and say can the grid handle
1.8 megawatts of of input right here and
the utility studies that and they come
back and they say yes but with these
upgrades and they'll give a list of way
we need this big giant it's called a
recloser it's like a utility grade
circuit breaker you'll have to you have
to install one of these and you might
need to upgrade this and that those
costs will actually be put onto the
private cost of the of the Solar
Development so
um additional distributed solar actually
results in additional private investment
in the local distribution grid which
benefits everyone and so that's why
there's some discussion another topic
but at the puc about maybe socializing
those costs more because they do benefit
representative Kaplan has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Reynolds for uh
testifying so eloquently on on your bill
um you're talking a lot about the the
costs uh relative to distribution and
transmission I wonder if you as someone
who's worked in the field professionally
I wonder if you have any notion of the
knock-on knock-on benefits that would
come from
employment figures say or small
businesses uh profits uh due to
increased solar penetration on on the
New Hampshire grid
thank you thank you for your for the
question representative Kaplan I
certainly do because that's what my
that's what my role used to be in
commercial solar sales uh again given as
I said that the
um fuel cost of solar is zero
the uh all the cost of solar almost all
the costs you have to maintain a system
there's a little cost to that but almost
all the cost of a solar system is
capital up front by the system
and when you do that
you can calculate
the engineering calculus says if you
build this solar system it's going to
produce this many kilowatt hours of
energy per year for the next
40 years and so up a a prudent business
or a prudent town
can say if we make that you know if it's
town of Exeter five million dollar
investment in this solar array
it's going to produce this many kilowatt
hours a year further next 40 years the
the levelized costs of those kilowatt
hours is
three and a half cents three and a half
cents a kilowatt hour
so yeah you can say and that's why
businesses private businesses from Bell
Events Beverage Company and your
District representative Thomas have put
a one megawatt solar array on their roof
of their building because the smart
businessman says
wow that's a good investment I can
protect myself from The Surge and boy
isn't he looking smart these days he's
getting all those kilowatt hours off his
Solar Ray and and not buying at 22 cents
a kilowatt hour from the utility
great investment and same thing North
Conway water Precinct 2 built a one
megawatt solar array boy are they
looking good to their rate payers
because they're they're running that
plant on
levelized costs solar power so much
cheaper than
what what's on the market today
okay thank you for answering that
question
representative regini has a question
thank you chairman and thank you for
taking my question this is a two-part
question of the four classes which one
um has the lowest capacity Factor so my
bill refers to only class two uh
solar PV so then my next question would
be why only increase Class 2 which is a
lower capacity Factor than all the
others and not increase one of the other
ones that has a higher capacity effect I
was only interested in increasing the
RPS for solar uh that's my bill
um I frankly the other I don't think
we're going to see a lot more
development of new Hydro so I don't you
know it's not reasonable to increase the
percentage of hydro because that's hard
to we're not going to really build any
more of that
so my build just focuses on solar
because it's very doable
and it's uh 100 private investment that
does it unless of course it's towns or
counties that do it on behalf of of
taxpayers so my bill just focuses on
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question or did you have a follow-up no
Wendy Thomas go ahead thank you Mr chair
um I'm just interested in lines 20 uh to
page two line two
how did you come up with those numbers
are they
um
accepted numbers are they from another
state
um they're just I thought that those
levels were reasonable
they're aspirational I took the I
definitely took the took the view that
uh
what exists must be possible
if you look at even those numbers you'll
see that they're lower than every other
state in New England already has
and so I certainly didn't want to
propose for new heaps or something that
was wildly aspirational or that people
could say that's hardly achievable you
can look left right and and you can look
in every direction and see states that
have already have solar renewable
portfolio standards that are stronger
than the numbers that I've proposed for
the State of New Hampshire I also uh did
this with the with the certainty that of
course I'm putting into law numbers that
would again it's aspirational set goals
for New Hampshire through 2050.
um you know if we get to 2030 and
I don't know it's kind of looks like we
topped out or anything more isn't
achievable it certainly would be within
the power of another
legislature to say oh you know maybe
maybe that number you have for 20 40 or
2050 isn't reasonable we'll roll that
back but
um in this case I'm trying to as I said
we're trying to turn the giant ship and
choose a destination
for 30 years from now 28 years from now
27 and uh
yeah so I thought those were very
reasonable numbers follow up follow up
um so what would happen if we don't make
the numbers in in each year is there a
penalty or anything
I mean this this is just changing the
numbers in the RPS so the RPS functions
that you know the utilities have to
acquire renewable energy
and when and when they do that they of
course get the wrecks the energy came
from Renewables so they have the wrecks
or they make alternative compliance
payments but that's not
you know contemplated here because again
these are not super ambitious numbers
do you have any idea how much it would
cost
to jump
fairly radically from
the current numbers of 0.7 percent to
the 3
2.53 3.5 percent numbers that you uh
aspire to with this legislation I I
don't have that number but I actually
don't think it's a huge jump I think as
as a matter of fact the New Hampshire in
the state where we're actually exceeding
the the anemic .07 number right now so I
don't think that that's
um
I I think that it we would be able to
achieve
[Music]
the three percent and the 3.5 fairly
easily and again
um
if we didn't actually have all the
remote which I'm confident that we do
have their own renewable energy
um you know people would make
alternative compliance payments and that
mechanism would function as desired by
cycling that money back into
uh supporting the development of more
renewable energy which would bring the
price of wrecks down as we heard in
testimony here before
you think it's reasonable as a follow-up
you think it's reasonable to ask us to
support legislation that we don't know
how much it's going to cost
I'm just going to gonna say this uh we I
think we do a lot of things that we
don't don't know how much they cost from
a totally different uh sphere I'm going
to pull the example of the educational
Choice Bill last year that was passed
they were the projected costs was some
low number and it's turned out that it
has cost the state way more than than it
was projected I mean this is again
um aspirational
but I believe easily achievable
we need
we need to Aspire to more basically
um you know when when John F Kennedy
told told the country we were going to
go to the moon in 1960 nobody
knew how much it was going to cost
nobody people doubted it was even
possible
but we did it
um this is we know how to do this this
is easy actually so I I'm not worried
about that it's going to be an onerous
cost given what I said about the zero
fuel costs it's just really all about
sparking the investment sending that
market signal to get more solar into the
market and I actually believe it will be
substantial benefit to the ratepayers of
so as another follow-up federal policy
recently
signed into law by President Biden
provides for a permanent 7 500 dollar
a tax credit to individuals who purchase
rooftop solar
it also made permanent investment tax
credits for commercial Enterprises that
with all that support from the federal
government do you still think it's
necessary to add additional support at
the state level to to stimulate the
adoption of renewable energy absolutely
and in fact I think that what you those
that those facts you just cited all
those first of all the the investment
tax credit for business investment in
solar and residential has existed for a
long time uh it was just sort of a
political football all the time and it
was in danger so it would it would
result in in sort of stop start you know
on inconsistent Market signal but so
you're right they made it permanent in
the in the ira but that those two things
will dramatically lower the cost of such
an aspirational uh goal as as increasing
the RPS because businesses and and
people that want to do it are going to
have that much more financial support
for it so more reason to to do it I
think we still need the market signal in
New Hampshire
to go ahead and do it does it really
lower the cost or does it just simply
transfer the cost to someone else namely
the American taxpayer
um you know again uh the the more solar
on the grid refer back to the iso
refer back to the iso graph the more
solar on the grid depresses the regional
demand depresses Regional price reduces
stress on
the regional grid reduces need for long
distance transmission
it's it's a big benefit and I haven't
even said one word yet about the
environmental benefits of more solar
which are very real and which people who
have uh suffer from
COPD or asthma
the cost of of our dependence on fossil
fuels for power generation especially at
peak times very real costs so I'm not
even talking about those costs but they
are very significant and very real so I
believe that there's significant savings
associated with this
in your testimony you also said that we
should not concern ourselves with
intermittency
but isn't intermittency a huge risk for
reliability
I I said that because I said the
regional
Market structures already account for
intermittency I said as policy makers we
ought not to write off Renewables
because they're intermittent everyone
understands that they're intermittent
and the market accounts for that by
discounting them in the forward capacity
Market that's why the capacity Factor
but that's it's already built in we we
say that we want to
have the market work
then let the market work it you know we
have Market structures that account for
the intermittency
and solar is used when it's available
if the markets were working
wouldn't people be able be in uh
motivated to purchase Solar without
the service it provides and its price
not necessarily
the market the energy Market that we
have uh is you know an evolution of
something that was invented over a
decade over a century ago it's a
government sanctioned highly regulated
Monopoly uh by necessity and for public
good but the structures in that market
are still uh tilted toward
um
you know fossil fuels Supply it's easier
to get large fossil fuel supply than it
is to
um
incentivize and get small distributed
solar that's why in the renewable
portfolio itself and the brexits
themselves are Market they were invented
to be part of the market and we just
need to have consistent policy to let
those Market structures work
so not increasing the RPS so for years
and years you know at every other state
has and we are benefiting from it that's
what the first ISO graph shows but we're
not doing our part so we just need to do
representative Kaplan has a question
yes uh thank you Mr chair and thank you
again representative uh just to give us
a little bit more of a granular view of
what it means to do our part
um and you know we're going in 2025 uh
fourfold increase from point seven to
three three percent minimum what uh just
to take 2025 as a baseline what are our
neighbor States what kind of minimums do
they have for solar well I just put them
I I meant to you know put them right
there for us all to see
um there's significantly significantly
you need a follow-up
nope
that's why it took you know
thank you Mr chairman
because of intermittency don't we need
to then build out a reliable source of
power in order to ensure we have power
when we need it
well no respectfully again the
intermittency is already accounted for
in the market structure of iso New
England solar's availability is heavily
discounted
so when they do the forward capacity
Market that's what they're doing what
she just said ensure we have reliable
backups or you say backup sources of
power the thing about the the grid of
course and our usage is
um usage and demand is highly variable
over 24 hour period so solar becomes
available obviously during the day
that's when we can dial back the fossil
fuel-fired power plants and so nobody's
I'm not against natural gas fired power
plants we need them both but we need
more solar and the bet we have the
benefit of more storage as again we
heard from another testifier within the
last couple of weeks how storage
Technologies are coming
coming on and now being proposed in
conjunction with the Renewables to
address the intermittency so now it
won't be completely Renewables are
completely unavailable you'll generate
during the middle of the day store it
and address that Peak at five and six
o'clock even with Renewables so we have
that back up if you will reliability in
the market it does that it's designed to
do that follow-up with all due respect
we do not have the battery storage
capacity now and what's been discussed
does only last for four hours so my
question concerned don't we need to
ensure through reliable manuf reliable
power sources that we have that
capability
um throughout an entire day
we polish we New Hampshire legislators
don't need to the New England
ISO New England and the power generators
Association of New England are
so just to clarify you're talking about
a gradual incentive working up to
certain levels of Solar Usage or were
you hoping to implement everything all
at once
no the um the bill is all about
increasing
the New Hampshire's renewable portfolio
standard very gradually
from
2024 to 2050
you know as the numbers show so it's
it's gradual increase in solar
follow up
so there would be a mixture of
if I'm understanding right using both
the fossil fuels that we have already at
hand as well as the onboarding of more
and more solar energy at the same time
kind of a transition from one to the
other yes absolutely that's I mean
that's what we have now is a portfolio
of sources and the regional grid
operator manages that and so it's just
about gradually
increasing the amount of solar I mean
thanks to the other State's policies
that's what ISO New England showed us
that is expected to happen so like I say
it's it's just it's just about getting
New Hampshire to do even
close to what the other states are
already
additional questions representative
Corman
thank you Mr chairman
so I'm thinking about
um chairman Bose's comments about uh a
free market
and uh you know clearly this is some
intrusion or let's say influence on the
market for solar
um are you aware of uh government uh
influence on the market for fossil fuels
and government support for for creating
those just I mean in terms of having a
Level Playing Field well sure I would I
would say that that's what that's the
default of of our system we have now in
my opening remarks I I sort of
um
colloquially describe the the rate
setting process at the puc as every six
months the utilities come and they say
this is the price of fossil fuels
and these are therefore these are the
rates we need to charge
and because the system is so highly
dependent on fossil fuels the puc says
ouch that boy in this case that really
hurt but open but okay
you know they can't say no
so that's where we get it's okay forever
sources rates to be 22 and a half cents
a kilowatt hour because the fossil fuel
which price is set on the global market
pass through to us
okay thank you we have one more person
who wants to testify on this bill so I'm
going to thank you for introducing it
thank you Mr chairman answering all our
questions and ask Griffin Roberts from
the Department of energy to give us his
thank you chairman Vos members of the
committee um for the record Griffin
Rovers from the New Hampshire Department
of energy
um depending on the any questions that I
might receive I have a hard stop at 2 30
as I have to leave
um regarding the other two bills this
afternoon House Bill 616 and 622 uh the
department will not be here to testify
on that those bills however we have
provided
letters of testimony uh to the committee
through the online portal if anybody has
any questions obviously feel free to
reach out anytime
um circling back to house bill 605 the
department is neutral
um as as it is uh introduced here the
bill as has been discussed makes two
primary changes to class two under the
renewable portfolio standard it makes an
immediate increase to class two's
obligation for electricity providers
from the current point seven zero
percent to two point 0.5 percent in 2024
and then it gradually increases the
class two obligations at the increasing
increments
um up to 25 by 2050 as detailed on page
one line 20 uh onto page two line two
um
electricity providers under this bill
will need to purchase an increased
amount of class II uh renewable energy
credits or wrecks to satisfy the
increased class two obligations it is
assumed that some of the uh obligation
will be met by electricity providers
making alternative compliance payments
or acps to the renewable energy fund
currently the rate for Class 2 acps is
59.12 and the ACP is indexed to half of
the Consumer Price Index and is adjusted
every year given that Rex operate in a
regional market it's difficult to assume
what portion of an electricity
provider's obligation will be met by
either purchasing wrecks or making acps
in the future
overall the Inc the increase in class 2
requirements will result likely in an
indeterminable increase in RPS
compliance costs again either through
electricity providers uh purchasing
um renewable energy credits wrecks or
making alternative compliance payments
and again as I think we all know those
costs are recovered by electricity
providers rate payers as well
doe did provide a revised fiscal note
dated
January 12 and we outline in that fiscal
note some of the bills maximum impacts
to electric rates I would reiterate to
the committee that these figures are
assumptions and actual bill impacts are
hard to predict given the rec Market
fluctuations year to year and with that
I'm certainly willing to answer any
representative buns
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
again for being here thank you um
I wanted to follow up on the the the
fiscal note and you know the the numbers
that are included in there because
they're you know they are very large and
sorry one of the things that um
that I that that that's missing and I
wonder if that data is available is
we we we're only showing a little piece
of the puzzle when we show that there's
potential additional ACP costs of 46
million dollars
because
um there's also a there isn't there is
an impact on rates but there's also
hopefully a impact on
the a positive or A positive impact on
rates as well
and we don't we we never get that
analysis is that type of analysis
available does the department of energy
have that there there has to be some
correlation between
increased expenditures and Renewables
and what the impact is we're you know
and granted I've only been on this
committee for a couple weeks now but we
never see that we never see what the
impact is sure
um thank you for the question so
regarding the figures um in the fiscal
note
um it is as I mentioned it is an
assumption that um the level of
electricity the total sale of
electricity from electricity providers
remains constant at 2021 levels that
inflation uh increases two percent a
year and uh it's assumed that the entire
increased obligation is met through acps
as you know we've discussed acps is the
higher cost of maintaining
um RPS compliance for electricity
providers so the these figures uh
represent as we know in the last
paragraph of the fiscal note indicate
the maximum potential increase to
Statewide electricity costs regarding
um the positive impact of of RPS
Investments
um there certainly is an argument to be
made that it redu that these types of
Investments reduce
um not only Regional transmission costs
but a state's allocation of transmission
costs I can take a deeper dive within
the department to see if we might be
able to work up a number for the
committee to have as a reference point
but it's not necessarily something that
we develop ourselves every year in
reporting and that type of thing because
rep prices fluctuate so much within the
market it's difficult to predict where
they might be in the future acps are set
in statute so they're relatively static
so we can make some assumptions there
but circling back to your point as to
the the benefits of the RPS is I think
you and I have discussed it is difficult
to quantify the that
holistically for all of the projects
because that requires some depth of an
economic analysis which we as a
department do not necessarily have but I
can certainly see what resources we
might have
um from ISO in terms of maybe reducing
transmission costs but I believe tell me
if I'm wrong I believe that
representative Reynolds might have
provided information with his testimony
follow-up
oh
I I I guess I would just caution sharing
numbers like this when it only includes
a part of the of the story yep and it's
misleading no no and um and and you know
and if the department doesn't have that
kind of analytical capability I would
suggest that as part of the budgeting
process you look to get that because you
know without that it's very difficult to
thank you I would remind the committee
uh to please make references to the bill
representative Doug Thomas has a
question
I just have one really quick question uh
regarding uh this bill here a simple
answer is there
anything in New Hampshire state
regulations that prevent
solar from being put on anyone's roof at
all any regulation that prevents it now
uh
something an outright regulation on that
no maybe there might be an indirect one
or something like that maybe like an
environmental impact but on the whole no
oh
follow up so okay so can I assume then
that um that a person can go and
purchase a solar panel and put it on his
roof now even even without this bill
representative munz has a question
um since I'm the numbers guy I'll ask
another numbers question
um hopefully simple
um the standard
um for class two currently
is somewhere between 0.3 and 0.7 where
are we actually uh thank you for the
question 0.7 is where we currently stand
and that's that's
expected to where it will remain
up to 2025 and Beyond follow-up under
current statute follow-up I'm I just
want to make sure that it was clear I
mean what the what what is the actual
performance not this not not what's
wrong oh you're talking about oh I
thought you're talking about the
obligation I'm sorry
um
I'm sorry the the actual performance I'm
sorry well there's a standard of points
between you know 0.7 yeah where are we
in terms of how we've actually where we
actually are in terms of I'm sorry
against that standard we measure that
each compliance year
um which tends to map out each uh tends
to follow the state's fiscal year so a
lot of that data is reconciled at the
end of the fiscal year to find out how
electricity suppliers have met their
obligation so I couldn't provide that
information right now but for a previous
compliance here much of that data is in
the uh renewable energy fund annual
report that I Pro that provided that's
the report I was looking for thank you
did you need me to provide that to the
community okay that's it
representative partial you had a
question
okay
all right see no further questions uh
for Mr Roberts we'll let him get off
on his way to Washington D.C thank you
thank you for being here and I hope you
make it to the airport on time
next up we'll invite Jennifer Smith from
Pembroke
sorry about that thank you chairman Ross
and members of the committee I'm
I I feel moved to to speak um because I
I just begin to feel like we have this
argument going on about whether this
couldn't just be done through free
markets
I am not an economist I'm a physician
retired physician with a public health
degree
I also own 20 kilowatts of solar on two
roofs
and I didn't do that because I thought
that I was going to make a killing doing
that
I I did it because of what are known as
externalities
and externalities are never valued in
the free market unless they're forced on
people by government
and that is in fact why so many places
are pushing hard on clean energy and I
think that's appropriate
and and
my father was an economist unfortunately
he died at 65 while working on how do
you value externalities for the
environment
it's still a very unresolved question
there is in fact a docket that is
ongoing about
valuing the um
contributions of
the energy in terms of just the standard
economic models because it's not a free
market we all know that
it's a highly regulated Monopoly
so let's be real about that
the ACP payments and to representative
Munn's point I get twenty dollars
or my
renewable energy certificates
the ACP payments are I believe still 55.
I don't think we're getting a lot from
the ACP payments so that's kind of a
bogus number to say what were the
maximum amounts of acps that would be
resulted that our utilities would have
to pay
they're paying a whole lot less for the
wrecks
and yeah the wrecks are important
although fewer projects get
value from that anymore
because we had to go to auctions my
solar was put up 2015 2018.
and so I did manage it but it was
difficult and the larger project really
depended on USDA Grant to make it work
we need to have a lot more clean energy
the costs the externalities in terms of
the impact on people's health
and they are substantial are not born
equally and those people living out in
nice neighborhoods of New Hampshire
don't understand as far as I'm concerned
how much damage fossil fuels are still
doing have done and are still doing and
we're only beginning to scratch the
surface
of just how serious that is
so I hope
that people will stop just arguing free
market economics when they look at this
thank you I'll be happy to take
questions
okay thank you very much
um I'd like to start the next hearing at
2 30 so if you have questions please
make them brief representative partial
like sure of those
um this question I had earlier but maybe
you could answer it um
understanding that in the past our our
natural gas prices were at a lower level
making solar less competitive to invest
in
um
but if we had done so and joined with
our New England neighbors that time do
you think that would have an effect on
Today's Energy prices yeah I think it
probably would because there would be a
lot more in our state and therefore the
distribution costs would be down because
those little places out there are having
solar on them reduces distribution costs
for everybody
because my neighbors use the electricity
I'm producing between
the late afternoon and the early evening
I did oh somebody else thanks for that
answer
okay thank you seeing no more questions
for
um Ms Smith
I thank you for being here and with that
we'll close the public hearing on House
Bill
605.
representative closure could you give us
a synopsis of the
blue sheets of all the bills we've heard
so far today that would be HB
281 298
558 and 605.
558 was recessed so you don't have to
give us that one but the other three
thank you chair
House Bill 280 281
a blue sheet and none in support to
oppose
online
to and support 70 oppose
House Bill 298
as a blue sheet
tour in support
three oppose
online
145 in support
House Bill 605
the blue sheet
or were in support none opposed on line
thank you representative we'll take a
three minute break and start the next
okay everyone I'm going to open a public
hearing on House Bill
6 16 Dash FN relative to the
administration of the New Hampshire's
renewable portfolio standard and
introduce the sponsor of the bill
representative Mark McLean from
Manchester
representative it's all yours and
welcome to St it's great to see you
Mr chair
honorable members of the Science Tech
and energy committee my name is
representative Mark McLean representing
Hillsboro district 15 which is
Manchester and I kind of view this
committee as one of the the Brain Trust
the legislature so
um I'm offering this testimony with
great humility and I hope you will
accept it in the spirit that it's being
offered so
um
HB uh 6 16 basically
um is a bill that is looking at the
renewable portfolio standard broadly
speaking it's uh divided up into two
categories the first category is
basically looking at the transferability
of uh of the wrecks so basically
um it allows a wreck that is you know
obtained from one class to be used
basically fungibly and
um the second part of the standards is
the creation of of a new class for new
nuclear so obviously the members of this
committee would know we're not talking
about Seabrook or something like that
the standard pressurized water reactor
we're talking new nuclear going forward
so the bill is uh fully supported uh by
the department of energy I've had some
conversations today with the folks there
and they see the bill as being full
fully in sync with their 10-year energy
strategy unfortunately when I spoke to
them they're not going to be able to
come here to testify today but they did
send in testimony in support of the bill
to you Mr chair and it should be
available for the clerk
so I'd like to go first of all and just
look at part one of the bill which is
basically you know the renewable energy
certificates and basically being able to
to transfer them from from one area to
the other and so what was the thinking
behind that so my thinking was I think
if I go back and put myself in the mind
of the creators of the renewable
portfolio standard I think what they
were trying to do at that point in time
was create kind of a New Hampshire
primary of Renewables so basically
you're creating many different classes
where all the different Renewables can
come in they have a swin Lane that kind
of protects them a little bit and gives
them a chance to to show their stuff you
know show everybody in the state you
know what their strengths are and kind
of make their case and that's that's
been the status quo for for a few
decades now but I think now having given
everybody a chance to to get out there
air and show what they're made of it's
time to kind of move beyond the primary
stage with the removal renewable
portfolio standard and get into the
general election as it were and to
really start to understand what are
those Renewables that are the best fit
for New Hampshire
um I don't think that Renewables are
ready yet to compete with
petroleum-based energy if they were then
we wouldn't need the renewable portfolio
standard so I think as they're getting
better and better and better and more
cost effective there may be and
hopefully will be a time when that comes
to be but they're not there yet but I do
think we are now at a point in time
where the Renewables are ready to
compete with each other and so the
thinking with this bill is that viable
options have to be given the room to
grow and even if that means you're going
to have to squeeze out some of the less
viable options and maybe some of those
less viable options are going to have to
be sacrificed so that those are a better
fit for New Hampshire is they're going
to be allowed to grow basically
a wreck is a wreck in this legislation
so under this bill if one renewable
crosses into another swim Lane so be it
one thing of note though is that when I
was originally looking to put in this
bill I was thinking is it time to just
go beyond the class system altogether
and just just let's just have a
classless renewable portfolio standard
and so in the iterations that I had with
the folks down at OLS they they really
counseled against that and I kind of
came around to their mode of thinking
and I think really at this point we
still want to preserve the definitions
that we have within the classes and one
of the examples that they brought back
to me as well you don't want to go and
have somebody burning tires for example
and that's biomass so that that is why
the bill uses the approach of retaining
the classes retaining the definitions
but just allowing for that trend
transferability between the classes
the second part of the legislation
basically creates a new class class 5
for new nukes to be fourth generation
molten salt reactors things of that
nature and my thinking behind that is
if for example I look at a country like
Switzerland Switzerland is a country
that really has been on the Forefront of
pursuing Renewables in its attempt to go
after climate change and
as they've expanded their Renewables
more and more and more they started to
say okay we really want to be
incorporating some of these Renewables
into the base load as well but the
problem they run into obviously at this
point is that while the Renewables
themselves are renewable be it solar
wind whatever
the battery storage that is needed to
basically store that energy that's not
renewable and you're basing that on
non-renewable minerals and things like
that so because of that the Swiss have
adopted a strategy going towards what
they call a 2 000 watt Society basically
this thing we don't think Renewables are
going to be enough we're going to have
to have conservation as well and so the
2001 they've kind of structured their
society to incentivize
that use unfortunately they've been
going after this for quite some time and
the the energy use is actually flatlined
it's still hanging around 6 000 watts
and in fact Switzerland hasn't been a 2
000 watt Society really since the 60s so
this has led them on to saying well how
what are some of the other ways we could
look at storage and they're looking at
hydrogen synthetic hydrocarbons things
of that nature but none of those are as
efficient as the the the battery storage
so what HB 16
616 seems to do is basically take a more
alexandrian approach
um the the
the average person in the United States
uses 12 000 Watts not 6 000 Watts so I
don't think really that that's a
long-term viable approach so another way
that you might encourage some growth in
the base load is to bring on new nuclear
um I think new nuclear has many
um attractive elements when it comes to
providing base load power it's clean
it's also sustainable I don't think it's
sustainable in the way of wind or
something like that but when you compare
it to petroleum and other resources
there's enough thorium on the planet to
basically last for tens if not hundreds
of thousands of years for so when you
look at it relatively speaking
um it it is as far as our society is
concerned a de facto a sustainable
source and there's already a commission
established to study new Nuclear So this
bill might be an arrow that the
commission may choose to to keep in its
quiver as it goes forward as I mentioned
before the bill is supported by the
department of energy as a more cost
effective way to to promote Renewables
um in kind of D segments that sector and
so um I hope that you will consider it I
think it offers a path forward to the
expansion of those Renewables that are
most in in sync with New Hampshire's
needs and I I hope you'll give it your
full consideration and that's my
testimony thank you Mr chair
thank you representative for introducing
this proposed legislation
questions from the committee
representative Kaplan has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
coming in to testify on your bill
um I think nuclear presents a sort of a
puzzle because it is a it's a viable
Baseline power source for us going
forward
however I questioned the
you know the placement of it in a
renewable portfolio standard because I I
don't think it is actually renewable I
mean it might be a zero carbon Source
but um the fact that it's still
producing waste that was going to be
around for hundreds thousands of years
um I think invalidates its
category it's categorical definition as
a renewable source and that that's
that's sort of is there a question there
yeah yeah sorry it's so my question is
how how do you how do you reconcile the
production of of the waste with the
definition of renewable sources
uh thank you for the question
um I think
um
I I look at it as renewable for a couple
ways um
first of all
um
if you look at thorium is I think the
39th most
um what's the word abundant mineral on
the earth so I think there there's lots
of thorium and in terms of uh the waste
disposal uh I think that there are
the the problem with disposal is and I'm
I'm not a nuclear scientist okay so I I
hope you take uh my answer in the spirit
that is offered but I think that the
challenges with disposal of nuclear are
are more political uh that than they are
technical I think you know there has
been talk in the past of storage with
with uh Yucca Mountain you could store
the waste in kind of a titanium Matrix
which would basically preserve it and
not allow it to get into water or things
like that and ultimately
um if you look at uh the half-life
something that's very radioactive also
has a very short half-life so I think
that a lot of the waste disposal issues
are technical
um but also if you look at when you're
looking at something like for example if
I wanted to use a base load uh and I'm
using Battery Technology to store it we
also I think have
um a lot of technical issues with
respect to what do we do with the the
left over batteries right so those are
those are technical uh problems as well
which I I think we we could address
um but I I think from the terms of is it
sustainable I think the disposal issues
can be addressed I'm just looking at it
as as a fuel source is it something that
as an end lifers we can see well into
the future so that's why that's why I'm
representative munz has a question
thank you uh Mr chairman thank you
representative for over here coming in
um
I'm not sure I know exactly what you're
referring to as new nuclear but when I
hear people talking about the next
generation of nuclear
um generation I I I I also hear them
talk in terms of like 20 30 40 years
from now
um and if that's what you're talking
about that's not really going to help us
it
um I I think the fact that we have a
commission specifically set up to study
how to bring new nuclear to the state
is an indication of the fact that um
we're much closer than 30 or 40 years I
think that there are and again I'm not a
nuclear engineer and so I want to
qualify my answer but I think
um
these are using a more abundant source
and again I think the the largest issue
with respect to these reactors has just
been
um the fact that if you're using for
example a molten salt a molten salt is
going to be highly corrosive and so you
have to develop Alloys and things that
are going to be able to to protect the
reactor vessel itself and I think
there's been a lot of research that's
been done removing oxygen from the
reactor working on the Alloys
um and so but again I'm not a nuclear
engineer and so I don't know all of the
answers to that but I think the fact
that we have a commission and they are
actively studying this shows that this
is something that's not 30 or 40 years
out
representative Thomas has a question
Doug Thomas said his thank you Mr chair
um thank you for taking my question so
uh to piggyback on uh representative
Muntz question
um are when you talk about nuclear are
are you referring to what we call
small-scale nuclear that is not only
five or ten years potentially in the
future but we also have some pilot
programs going on in this country as it
is now is that what you're referring to
when you're talking about nuclear class
five
yes the the bill is speaking to Gen 4
and later nuclear so obviously it
wouldn't be a Seabrook it would be just
what you're talking about yes that's
correct
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um if I read this bill correctly on page
two you're removing all funds that um
are used by the doe to support thermal
and electrical so basically
and I'm using my words carefully here
you want to Nuke all Renewables in New
Hampshire that's a pretty drastic
proposal so my question to you is I'd
like to know with whom did you consult
um
I consulted with with OLS primarily but
I don't the
the
renewable the alternate compliance
payments they still go into the um
what's it called
they still go into the um
renewable renewable energy fund which is
a non-lapsing fund so I think that money
follow up
um but yet that part is stricken out on
foreign
out because everything is going to a
standard uh fee of
55 dollars
um
55 across the board to be deposited into
that fund per each megawatt hour not met
by the uh
just one more so representative I think
if I understand your question correctly
you're assuming that this language
completely removes
renewable energy incentives
but that's not the case what this
legislation does is it eliminates the
different classes
puts all Renewables in one class where
they compete against each other
for the sale of wrecks including the
addition of this new class five
is that
um that that clarifies it yeah the
source of your confusion thank you thank
you
representative Summers has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um speaking on small-scale nuclear
um which is I know being tested
currently by the U.S Navy for production
of submarines and and future and
aircraft carriers is it not true that
there is no waste from small-scale
I I don't
I'm not a nuclear engineer as I said but
I think that there is still some waste I
think they're very efficient because of
the way the moderator is structured but
I don't think that there is no waste I
do know
that you can use spent fuel depending
upon how the reactor is configured you
can use spent fuel say from Seabrook as
representative Kaplan has another
question
yeah it's similar to my first question
um in terms of the nuclear fitting into
the renewable portfolio standard
um you know from the way there is a
question here so just bear with me but
the way I see it the Renewables all have
uh lots of things in common besides
they're being renewable that and the
fact that they're intermittent the fact
that they're distributed
this the nuclear even though they're
small
um
they really fit more on the model of you
know the traditional electrical
generation power stations centrally
located you know
so wouldn't the placement of these new
nuclear
um generate generating uh sources
distort the renewable portfolio standard
and miss and displace to a certain
extent that the quote unquote
I think that
as you go forward if you want to reduce
your carbon emissions then you're going
to have to have some kind of
base load element
and I think that this
will work in tandem with those other
forms of Renewables and so I actually
believe it is well placed
on representative kaplan's question
one of the purposes of the renewable
portfolio standard is to incentivize the
development of new generation sources
by putting nuclear small-scale nuclear
into the RPS
you'd be adding an incentive to generate
to to create new sources of of
electricity so doesn't that make it
logical as a place to put
that was that was absolutely my thinking
um I I just don't think if I look at the
example of the Swiss
going to
rely on conservation to reduce your base
load is just this is
you're going to need to find a way to
incentivize new technologies that
provide base load to complement your
other Renewables and this is a
sustainable clean source that allows you
to do that and so the intention is to
representative Reynolds uh you're the
prime sponsor of this bill so
no no you're not sorry
I'm sorry representative Reynolds is
recognized
thank you Mr chairman
um I have a good question that's a
follow-up on actually representative
Muntz question but before I ask it I I
just want to assure representative
Summers and everyone else that I I live
across the river from the Portsmouth
Naval Shipyard where of course they
bring in nuclear submarines and repair
them and I assure you that the
reactors on those subs do have nuclear
waste which they take off of the subs
and remove
be a train in the middle of the night
and the Navy doesn't like to talk about
it and as local politicians we're not
supposed to talk about it but there's
certainly waste and believe me I'm
excited for the day that that technology
could be modularized and there could be
small nuclear reactors let's get back to
the bill please so the question is
following up representative munzel's
rather general what
can you give us sort of a a year that
you think uh what is the day the date on
which a one of these new modular
reactors might bid its capacity into the
forward capacity Market or bid its
output to the uh provide the energy to a
community power plan what what year are
we talking 2030 are we talking 20
35 or 2040 based on your
whatever you've read or studied
what year I mean I'm I'm just going to
go I I I think you're looking within the
decade
we're in 2030.
within the decade so you know five ten
years I think you're looking within a
decade but I'm not a subject expert so I
don't think I can get more specific than
that
the NRC has licensed
uh new scale small-scale reactors
already so it's just a matter of
representative partial appears to have a
question
yes uh knowing that there are two
experimental uh
stations in existence now
there's nothing I'd like to see more
than see these
um that's a two-part question actually
but see these uh incentivized but do you
feel that perhaps it may be too soon to
have this written in a law when there's
not one commercially viable station out
there
this is a very promising technology
and I think that I would like to see New
Hampshire on the front end of that
technology rather on than on the back
end of that technology I would I think
that we could potentially if there's an
opportunity for us to be a leader in
this area why not go for it and I think
this would incentivize that
follow-up
and do you feel that market forces being
what they are if this is so is promising
as we all hope it actually is do you
feel that they need this type of
incentive to move it forward or will
Market forces a free market
um
instead of as act as incentive enough to
produce these types of plants
I think that there's it's a new
technology and
um as with all nuclear there's going to
be Capital costs and
um so I think when you're bringing in a
new technology uh this is this is a
great way to incentivize it it's not
like this is something that is an
already existing technology where I
could just go and you know let the
market forces come in the renewable
portfolio standard was in fact set up
recognizing that some of these other
Technologies needed room to come in and
kind of have a run path to build
themselves up
you know I know what's the third
question may I representative munz has a
question
thank you Mr chair
um just to make sure I'm clear
um the the new class of nuclear class
five is it that we're talking about
um that would be included in the overall
renewable portfolio standard right so in
2025 the standard would be 25.2 percent
that would include nuclear as well yes
that that would include that as well
okay seeing no further questions for the
prime sponsor I want to thank
representative McLean for introducing
this legislation we have
three more people who would like to
testify on this bill between now and 3
30.
so
we're actually between now and three
o'clock which is three minutes so I'll
call on Heidi Kroll from the granite
and welcome back to sdne Ms Crowell nice
to see you
very much Mr chairman and members of the
committee I will be brief recognizing
the time
um my name is Heidi Kroll I work at
Gallagher Callahan and gartrell and I'm
here today representing the granite
state hydropower Association which is a
voluntary Association of New Hampshire's
very small scale Hydro facilities of
five megawatts or less we have about 55
megawatts in total across the membership
in about 35 or so cities and towns
throughout the state we are strongly
opposed to House Bill
616 and we would encourage this
committee to find it in expedient to
legislate
um
as far as I'm aware there is no other
RPS
um program certainly in New England
which New Hampshire is part of the New
England Market that um has eliminated
all of its classes and added nuclear to
the um to the program uh so our feeling
is that this would represent a
significant departure from the purpose
of the New Hampshire RPS law which is to
support diverse locally distributed
small-scale existing and new Renewables
um
and uh if we were to allow nuclear in
our concern is among many others is that
this would essentially swamp much of the
RPS program which would in turn
um cause a lot of harm for New
Hampshire's in-state small-scale uh
existing and potentially new Renewables
coming down the road
um our current law was carefully
designed to ensure that we promote and
benefit from a diverse portfolio of
renewable facilities in terms of their
fuel source their technology their age
and their size and that's how the four
classes came about I was actually around
during the years leading up to all the
work that went into
crafting the RPS there were several
years of of very careful study with this
committee and its counterpart in the
Senate and I did go back and pull the
original bill which created the RPS law
this was
passed in 2007 if I'm remembering
correctly and I just wanted to read this
piece here
um
uh one principle one guiding principle
that was used that was coming out of the
state energy policy commission which had
been established in 2006
um one principle is and this was in the
um the findings that uh
led up to they're not you won't find
them in the statutes but they're in the
bill it says one principle is to
increase the state's fuel diversity by
reducing the fossil fuel component of
the state's Energy Mix and promoting use
of renewable energy resources to buffer
against Global instability and I think
that's
seems to really still hold true today
two other points I'll quickly make
before I wrap it up
uh
investors in renewable small-scale
renewable facilities here in New
Hampshire look for stability in terms of
policy they're making long-term
Investments whether it's reinvestment in
existing facilities or its investment in
new facilities so the stability of
policies expectations is very important
um
and I guess yeah stability and policy
consistency so with that I'm happy to
answer any questions
um
that concludes my testimony
thank you nice job two minutes and 45
seconds
uh representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so you said that
you're concerned that allowing nuclear
into the RPS standards would swamp much
of the program do you have any estimate
for how much of the RPS would be
satisfied by a nuclear compared with all
the other classes that we currently have
I don't I mean listening to the
testimony it sounds like it's it's new
small-scale nuclear which is not even
kind of commercially available right now
um obviously if it was something like
Seabrook station
um that would just you know
multiple folds I think um swamp with the
um you know the uh amount of kilowatt
hours that's required currently under
representative Doug Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair uh thank you
for taking my question so you mentioned
back in 2007 and that was a time period
I believe uh where no one even ever
considered that they would ever ever be
nuclear in this state again because of
Seabrook and so forth but here we come
along with some new technology would
what would be your rationale uh on on
this bill uh to that that would prevent
new technology that would come in that
might even be more efficient than what
we have now in the in the interest of
progress uh do you think we could all
live together with that
I'm all for progress and and certainly
if it's clean technology
um I I think
um that makes a lot of sense I'm just
um our position simply is that putting
it into the RPS statute is probably the
seeing none I want to thank you Miss
Crow for giving us your perspective on
this uh legislation proposed legislation
I'd like to Now call on
Meredith Hatfield from The Nature
Conservancy to give us her take on this
bill
thank you Miss afternoon
welcome back thank you I um
Meredith Hatfield for The Nature
Conservancy I agree with everything that
miss Kroll said and I think she said it
better than I could have so I won't be
repetitive but um I also had the
privilege of participating in the
development of the RPS back in 2006
including a very extensive stakeholder
process that Des LED that brought all of
the interest together to develop our RPS
so I would urge the committee to find
this bill in expedient to legislate and
instead urge you to consider these
issues perhaps in another setting
perhaps There's an opportunity to study
this issue and consider if the state
wishes to incentivize Technologies other
than Renewables because nuclear energy
respect with all due respect is not
renewable you could consider looking at
what other states are doing in in this
Arena creating mechanisms like a clean
energy standard and you would decide
what qualifies for clean so some states
are running the RPS and the CES in
parallel and I would also urge caution
since last year in House Bill 543 you
created the commission to investigate
the implementation of Next Generation
nuclear reactor technology in New
Hampshire
and representative Harrington is the
vice chair of that committee so it's too
bad he's not here with his background in
nuclear issues but that body has been
meeting and if you look at their
December 1st 2022 report they said that
they're still in the investigatory
phases exploring the issues and that
they do intend to make recommendations
potentially for legislation but also for
other actions that the state could take
so that we are ready when this
foreign
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
coming back as as someone that was
involved in the development of the um
the the renewable portfolio standards
um
is there a place in those standards for
encouraging the development of of
storage
I'm I'm reading a lot about
alternative batteries I mean Iron air
batteries for example uh and we've heard
a lot of testimony today on you know the
challenges that lack of battery capacity
has and it its impact on encouraging
development but is that something that
should be
that where the that could be addressed
through the renewable portfolio standard
thank you for the question um and I
should say an apologies to the chair
because I know this is a little off
topic
I as has been testified
um by many experts before you storage
really is going to be a game changer and
it it's already being deployed today as
you know but um it really will help make
intermittent resources available to us
at more times of the day and I would
note
um that we do have programs in New
Hampshire to help try to incentivize
storage but they are quite small
compared with other states and other
states are doing pilot programs right
now to test the cost effectiveness of
storage and it is pretty exciting
because even for buildings that don't
have their own distributed generation so
for example solar some storage programs
are showing cost Effectiveness even when
you are charging batteries from the grid
and they also provide tremendous
resilience benefits when the power does
go out so they do have a lot of
potential applications and and I think
that they do make sense when we're
thank you seeing no further questions
I'll thank you for being with us this
afternoon thank you look forward to
seeing you in the future
the last pink card I have for today
will bring forward Mr John Gage
representing himself and Mr Gage has
requested three minutes so Mr Gage we
thank you chairman and committee members
um I'll try to keep it to one because
most of what I wanted to say was just
said by the last two people
um
you know one of the major things you can
do as a a committee that helps energy in
our state is provide stability in the
market uh conditions that that energy
providers use to make decisions and uh
it sounds like adding nuclear to the RPS
portfolio mix will destabilize a lot of
current policy that energy providers are
using right now to make plans
nuclear is not a solution in the short
term for climate pollution in the next
10 years our country's committed to 50
reductions of greenhouse gas emissions
and it takes a long time to to roll out
a nuclear plant to do that we need
solar and wind and storage rolling out
is you know rapidly as as we can the
reason that would be good for our state
so we shouldn't change the RPS rules
right now we we should be encouraging
more of those not destabilizing
um those providers carbon pricing is
inevitable it's in 68 countries and
regions around the world
um prices are rising the EU is about to
start charging our exporters their
carbon price on high energy intensive
Goods the writing is on the wall the
federal government is going to price
carbon soon
we should be doing what we can
to prepare for that
um nuclear is a great option but it's
not going to help us in the short term
reducing emissions I do agree we need
firm power we're going to need 15 or 20
percent of nuclear power in the long
term so we should look to how to
incentivize that but please don't
destabilize the short-term renewable
policies that we've got in place right
now
well done
two minutes four seconds
appreciate that uh questions for uh Mr
Gage representative cornman
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr Gage
uh you said that you you think that we
should not be changing the RPS does that
mean that you feel like the current
percentages that we have for the classes
in the RPS should not change no I'm
sorry uh as pertains to this bill they
should not change I was at a hearing in
the Senate energy environment where
somebody suggested greatly increasing
the requirements for uh solar generation
and I think that's the direction we
should be going
um I don't I didn't want it watered down
by adding nuclear which would would
basically swamp the the Renewables that
are being supported right now
we should be doing more
representative pleasure has a question
thank you chair uh thank you Mr Gage uh
just for clarification
do you do you believe
we should be looking and probably
incentivizing the new generation nukes
but not
in this area
yes I think nuclear is an important
long-term solution
um Seabrook isn't going to last forever
we should be looking forward to how
we're going to be replacing that
um the the bow cold plant is going to go
away that would be a good place to put a
uh a small modular reactor
um we should be looking at these things
but we should not destabilize the
deployments of solar and wind that we
have going right now we should be
increasing those giving the market
stability to to ramp those up and doing
okay seeing no further questions we
thank you for being here today and
giving us your perspective on this
proposed legislation
seeing no more pink cards on this bill
I'm going to close the public hearing on
House Bill 616.
and thank representative McLean for
introducing this legislation
and now I will open a public hearing on
House Bill 622
which is an act that
repeals
the Energy Efficiency and sustainable
energy board
and call on the bills Prime sponsor
representative J.D Bernardi to introduce
this legislation
and remind everyone that we need pink
cards if you have an an intention to
Mr chairman I have a question
representative Summers what's your
question just to verify from this
morning I know I'm a co-sponsor on this
so as long as I don't testify I'm
allowed to ask questions correct that is
representative Bernardi it's all yours
thank you Mr chairman uh I'm
representative JD Bernardi Rockingham 36
which is Hampton Falls
Kensington Southampton Newton and
Plaistow
um I Rise to present uh
this current let this current bill
um and I have provided you which is a
bill which would essentially in my view
consolidate uh further consolidate
functions
um in the department of energy as part
of the overall transition that divided
the puc from uh from and created a
department of energy
and that is to move the easy board the
remaining easy board functions back into
the department of energy
so what what I gave you a handout which
contains the uh the statute that created
the easy board and its functions and you
the second page uh is is I find very
interesting it's the easy board uh
statement of governing principles
and and there's there's only two things
that they currently still have yet to do
because one of the main functions that
they had up until last session was to
recommend uh changes to
um system benefit charge rates but we
changed that to be a legislatively
mandated uh amount with an escalator on
an annualized basis so what remains is
promoting and coordinating Energy
Efficiency demand response and
sustainable energy programs in the state
and to make recommendations regarding
that all the rest of the easy boards uh
operational functions
a through H are
essentially administrative who sits on
the board how the meeting meetings occur
how you get the um
information to and from the board but
there's nothing there just describing
the policy
um
the department of Energy's
responsibilities they're
key is key among them is making policy
making possible increased efficiency and
economics from integrated Administration
and that that mission is part of the uh
energy
um is also parroted in the mission
statement affordable inevitable reliable
and sustainable energy economy and that
tasking is given to the division of
so as I looked at what's left of the
easy boards life it seems to me it's
redundant it fits in the department of
energy and hence the legislation that
I've proposed
thank you representative Bernardi for
introducing
this legislation
before I entertain questions for you
from the
um
members of the committee I'd like to
read the a portion of the letter
submitted by Jared chicoine the
commissioner of the Department of energy
regarding this legislation
the department has adopted a neutral
and they say that
if the legislature decides to move
forward with
this re organization of
easy board tasks the department of
energy will be willing and able to take
on their responsibilities transferred in
House Bill 622 with no need for
so I just wanted that to be clear thank
you uh members
have questions for representative
Bernardi representative Noel has a
question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question uh does the bill
disband the easy board and just reassign
the duties to the Department of energy
or is the board just reconstituted in
the department of energy no the the
concept is to to disband the board and
transfer the responsibilities to the
Department of energy
um and and hence save money one of the
taskings we've heard continually through
this this year is we have too many
commissions too many boards uh we don't
even have the people to uh
sit on these boards to make to make them
functional
when I looked at this board and looked
at the tasking of the new Department of
energy this seemed to fit right within
their
basket of tasks and and it was a
redundant or parallel board that we
already have a state plan on energy
these folks work on plans that the
energy
sustainability Energy Efficiency ought
to be a part of that state plan so why
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um can you please give me an idea of the
time commitment for this board how often
they meet
um how much they're I mean what time is
involved in this
I am going to ask our chairman to answer
that question as he is a member of the
board and can give a better answer than
I
I'd be happy to answer that question I
do serve on the easy board I've been on
two plus years now and the board meets
monthly at the department of energy
headquarters
The Walker building on
um what's the name of that street well
Hayes and drive up the street no it's
not Hazen drive it's all Pleasant
off Pleasant yeah yeah anyway
um
so they meet monthly
um the members of the board
probably don't have a lot to do
individually
between meetings the board chairman and
vice chairman have work to do to set the
agenda and organize the meetings and
arrange for speakers to come before the
board so there is some work to be done
there
um
but beyond that
there is no real extensive time
commitment for members of the board
that answer your question yeah it does
thank you very much
representative Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman I my experience
with the easy board is is a little bit
in the past so yours is probably more
recent but I know that it's one of its
principal functions is to bring
uh non-governmental voices into the
conversation with
you know that what was then
uh you know predecessors to Department
of energy now to the Department of
energy so our
I I hear I see the letter that the doe
says we could take over the
responsibilities but are are you at all
concerned that losing the venue uh of
input from people who are not of the
Department of energy that that would be
a loss to the state
uh
I I believe the department of energy
when it's addressing its state plan or
any of these issues can call whatever
members it wants and at whatever
resources it wants to investigate and
flush out uh issues that it's working on
and and to do that they probably will
call on external forces or external uh
talent to to address those questions so
I'm not worried about any loss of of uh
potential outside information
okay seeing no further questions for the
prime sponsor I want to thank you for
introducing this legislation
and I only have one pink card left so
I'll call on Meredith Hatfield
to testify give us and give us her
perspective on this
legislation welcome back thank you very
much good afternoon Meredith Hatfield
for The Nature Conservancy
um
my colleague Bruce Clendening actually
had the privilege of chairing the easy
board over the last year
um and so I just wanted to acknowledge
his service to the to the easy board and
I had the privilege of being one of the
original members when it was first
created
I I do think that
um the easy board perhaps in a new
version could still really provide
um benefits to the folks who are trying
to learn about these issues and Advance
them
and I I think if the department of
energy is willing to take on these tasks
um I think that's a wonderful thing I I
one thing I I did want to raise for your
consideration
is the public input aspect of the easy
board and and that educational that open
sort of free exchange of ideas and
information and I just wanted to note
the members of the easy board that you
set into statute a number of years ago
that include
legislators which I think is really
valuable for folks in the field and in
state government to have places where
they can informally interact with
legislators and hear about your
priorities and your questions and also
share their views
um having the Bia at the table
Des the Department of Business and
economic Affairs the municipal
Association New Hampshire legal
assistance on behalf of their low-income
clients the home builders and remodelers
Association I think has really brought
some really
um unique and helpful perspectives to
some of these questions
um
and there are other agencies on on the
easy board as well I won't go through
each one but you know I I would
encourage you to think about how to
ensure that
um there's some type of a venue for the
Department of energy to hear from folks
in the field and I would note that
during the development of the last
um State energy strategy I think because
of the pandemic there were not public
hearings or public meetings held to
gather input whereas back in 2014 when
we did the first state energy strategy
we did field hearings all around the
state which was really a helpful way to
talk to people you know in different
parts different corners of the state so
I would urge you that if you go in this
direction
to to perhaps
and monthly meetings probably aren't
necessary but to have some ability for
the public to interact with the
Department
from you know a variety of perspectives
and to be able to share information from
the field because some of those folks
Implement our programs and like the cap
agencies attend the easy board often and
it's really helpful to hear directly
from the folks on the ground and just
one other example of where I I have
found the easy board to be really
helpful is there have been a couple of
presentations on the federal funding
that will be available that is relevant
to these types of programs whether it be
Energy Efficiency or distributed energy
and that that is just such a resource
for people who are trying to serve
customers serve clients
build businesses in New Hampshire so
having that place that you can go and
have that free exchange of ideas and
share information I think is is is
invaluable and as someone who's had the
The Good Fortune of serving in state
government I can tell you
um you know it really enriches
um has enriched my ability to to feel
like I was
um advancing policy issues with an ear
toward what what folks in New Hampshire
cared about
thank you Miss Hatfield for your
perspective
you raised an interesting point in your
testimony you said
that you'd like to see
a vehicle for public input should the
department of energy take over this
function
would you think that it would be
advisable for us to amend this
legislation to create maybe a an
Advisory Board
with members of the public
who could serve in a
quarterly or a semi-annual
advisory capacity to the Department
thank you representative Vos
um you know I think that that is
certainly one one possibility I I would
certainly
um want to have you here directly from
the Department of energy about what
might work for them and what other
structures they might have on different
topics that they find useful I would
also note that the assistant
Commissioner of Des is now the new chair
of the easy board and he certainly has
vast experience with public processes
and I think Des has a number of those
types of boards and and advisory
committees so I think that um between
uh the leader new leadership of the easy
board and Folks at the doe they may have
some good thoughts about the best way to
follow-up can you elaborate a little bit
about about the advisory boards within
Des
so two that um come to mind are the
rivers and lakes advisory committees and
I'm probably not getting their names
exactly right they're two separate
bodies but they work with Des to provide
you know citizen input about rivers and
lakes and I and I've heard Des testify
that they find them to be very helpful
when there's people on the ground you
know watching for lakes and rivers
issues that it's really helpful
excellent thank you
further questions from Miss Hatfield
representative muns thank you Mr
chairman thank you again for testifying
I I share your concern about the lack of
or the loss of uh input from some of the
constituents constituencies that you you
identified and
um you you you actually or chairman Voss
actually asked my question and you
answered it and I guess I would say that
you know I would certainly be open to
trying to do something to create some
kind of an Advisory Board
within the department of energy
thank you and let me say too that it's
not just about the department hearing
from the public the public I think is
hungry to hear from the Department as
well so really having that that two-way
additional questions for Miss Hatfield
see none I want to thank you for coming
by this afternoon to uh add your
perspective to this discussion thank you
and having no additional pink cards for
this legislation I'll call this public
hearing closed and ask representative
closure to give us some blue sheet
information about the two bills we heard
this afternoon or the three bills
uh thank you chair I believe I gave 605
I can give it again
no not necessary if you already gave it
thank you
House Bill 616 blue sheet one in support
five opposed
online foreign support
House Bill 622
blue sheet
none and support to oppose
online to and support 98 a post thank
you
thank you very much before we conclude
our business today although I would like
to get everybody out of here a little
bit early
have a couple of things that I want to
talk about one number one is at the
beginning of
today's meeting I suggested that next
week because we lose Tuesday due to a a
session a house session that we would
likely have a committee day on either
Thursday or Friday
well after consultation with uh
representative hunt who chairs the
Commerce Committee which with whom we
share this room
it turns out they have already scheduled
this room for Thursday so it looks like
if we meet again a second time next week
there is a possibility that uh we won't
meet that day I have to figure that out
tonight I have to determine how many
bills we have left to hear Etc
I do have a conflict that day the easy
board meets that that day so
um
if we didn't have to meet that day that
would be that would be useful because
I'm sure the easy board is going to want
to ask me what happened at the public
hearing here today
so
I would ask you all to reserve Friday
until
I know next Friday Friday the 17th and
excuse me would that do I need to raise
my hand representative Wendy Thomas
thank you um would that in involve an
executive session as well on Friday or
is it just bill hearings
potentially it would involve executive
sessions too we we have to keep up with
the
with the executive sessions otherwise
we'll find ourselves in a position
I've I've talked about this before we'll
find ourselves in the position that we
were in last year where we had this huge
ton of bills dumped on the house floor
all at once and we ran out of time to to
address them and so the speaker asked me
to table bills
itl bills so there was no debate on the
house floor on those bills
well not only would that be difficult
this year because many of our bills are
going to end up going to the house floor
without recommendation
it would be impossible you know you
can't table a bill that's without
recommendation I don't think I suppose
you could but I don't think a tabling
motion would pass so
um so I'm trying to avoid the situation
where we dump
25 bills on the house in two days so
we're trying to keep up with with the
executive sessions and getting these
bills out the door that's that's that's
representative Gorman
thank you Mr chairman what's the time
frame for when we have to get all our
bills out and exact I'm counting that we
uh I don't have my calendar right in
front of me but I think the deadline to
finish all bills is somewhere around the
20th of March
so
um representative Thomas has his
all remaining house bills is
last day to report on all house bills
not in a second committee
last day to report all remaining house
bills is March 20th
or 30th rather I misread that 30th
so
basically what that means is they all
have to be
on the house floor by March 30th
so typically you would try to get them
there before the 30th but seems to me
that we have enough time then that we
shouldn't have to use Friday next week
if we have 11 more to hear and you know
that plus the ones that we've heard and
have been exact it seems like we have
time
well that's one of the things I have to
representative Thomas and representative
Bernardi and I have to get our heads
together and collaborate and figure out
exactly how we can get the remaining
bills heard
and exact in conformance with these
dates
so I that's why I'm asking you to
reserve Friday we may need it we may not
um
the alternative would be to meet during
the week of vacation
even though the house Speaker has asked
us not to meet that week
that doesn't mean we we can't meet that
week we can
um so that would be the alternative
so if you want that week off
then you'll make yourselves available to
meet before that so we can have that
right okay
and then there was one other thing I was
yes we we lose President's Day Monday
the 20th
so that's a that's another reason why
we're
we've already lost one Monday now we're
going to lose the second Monday we've
lost one Tuesday and then we lost
another Monday because of snow so we've
lost four
committee days which potentially if
could allow us to we made up the snow
day we did make up the snow day but
we're still behind we're still behind so
I'm I'm sorry did you were you serious
about us meeting during winter vacation
I said it's an option and one I'd really
really like to avoid uh all right well I
okay does anybody else have anything
else they want to uh bring to the
attention to the committee
seeing nothing I will thank you all for
your hard work these last two days and
uh
we'll see you uh
what is today yeah today's Tuesday we'll
see you next Tuesday
and the uh next Monday the Delta Dental
thing is tonight as well
Delta Dental
it's it's oh that's tonight yeah that's
tonight I'd lost track of that so there
is a reception for for Delta Dental I
cannot go because I have a deliberative
session in my town
I have to be there so
I can't go to Delta Dental to all right